Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio Nummer 238 live auf der Marienstraße 11, wo wir heute eine der wichtigsten, wichtigsten, wichtigsten Fragen klären, die ich mir jeweils gestellt habe. Aber nein, das Chaos Radio ist nicht zu meiner persönlichen Show verkommen. Es ist auch eine, die sich anbietet, weil ja bald Studienbeginn ist. Und damit sind wir schon fast mitten im Thema. Wir wollen über ein Studium reden, über eins und zwar das Informatik Studium. Und dazu gibt es hier im Umfeld des Chaos Computer Clubs, in dem wir uns ja heute Abend befinden. Naja, man könnte sagen, es gibt so zwei Aussagen. Das eine ist ein sehr beliebtes Studienfach. Platz 4 in der Top 10 der Studiengänger. Und andererseits gibt es die Redewendung, dass man nur ein richtiger Hacker sei, wenn man ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium vorzuweisen hat. Aber man kann schon mal festhalten, ein Informatikstudium scheint so oder so wichtig. Die Frage ist nur, macht man es zu Ende oder nicht? Und ob das der Fall ist, das wollen wir heute klären. Dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Andreas Brog. Hallo und guten Abend. David Weber, auch Widdister genannt. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Mutags. Hallo und guten Abend. Und Tobias Fiebig. Hallo und guten Abend. Und ihr alle habt die Eigenschaft Informatik... Ja, ich muss es jetzt mal richtig formulieren. Ihr habt ein Informatikstudium angefangen. Habt ihr alle gemacht, oder? Ah, noch nicht.
Gut.
Warum bist du denn hier?
Ich bin Auszubildender als Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration.
Ach, man kann Informatik auch anders lernen als an der Uni?
Ja, ich denke.
Na gut, wir sind voll das, das klären wir auch heute. Aber ihr habt gut, aber die Berufswahl Informatik war für euch irgendwann mal gut. Fangen wir mal links auf dem Sofa an, Andreas. Warum hast du dich entschieden, Informatik zu studieren?
Naja, ich hab so Dinge mit Computern getan, das erschien mir naheliegend.
Wie im Sinne von ich habe jetzt keine bessere Idee und deswegen mache ich das jetzt und ich weiß noch gar nicht, was da hinten rauskommt?
Ja, so ungefähr. Ich dachte mir, naja, ich will programmieren und die bringen einem das bestimmt bei und das ist sicherlich spannend. Deswegen habe ich damit mal angefangen. Also es war kein besonders kreativ- schöpferischer Währungsprozess. Es war ja auch eine Zeit vor dem Internet, wo man sich noch nicht so richtig darüber informieren konnte, wie die Welt da draußen so aussieht.
Ich habe mich seit ich denken kann mit Computern beschäftigt und bin dann auch irgendwie in diesen Chaos Computer Club gerutscht und in diese komplette Hacker-Szene und dann war es für mich klar, dass ich auch beruflich mein Hobby, also mein Hobby zum Beruf machen will. Und es war dann für mich eher ein Zufall, dass ich die Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker begonnen habe. Aber genau, es war für mich eigentlich schon immer klar.
Also Zufall im Sinne von irgendjemand ist angekommen, hat gesagt, hier, wie wär's denn so? Ach ja, habe ich gerade nichts besseres zu tun?
Ja so ähnlich. Ich habe mich eigentlich eher auf eine Stelle beworben, weil mir jemand gesagt hat, ich soll mich doch einfach mal da bewerben, das Unternehmen sei cool. Und plötzlich wollten die mich auch.
Und dann war eine Ausbildung mit dran?
Ich habe erstmal gar nicht Informatik gemacht, weil ich stinke Langeweile ich fand. Also ich habe sehr viel mit Elektronik gemacht als Schüler, als Kind. Habe dann vier Semester Elektrotechnik gemacht und dabei gelernt, dass Informatik total spannend ist und dann den Studiengang gewechselt. Aber ich habe es erstmal nur so kennengelernt, als die sind total theoretisch und das ist irgendwie total abgehoben und langweilig.
Na ja, ob das dann schon der Slammer noch macht. Tobias, wer war's bei dir?
Also bei mir war es auch eigentlich erst so, dass ich nicht wirklich Informatik studiert habe, jetzt aber zum Ende dann doch wieder da reingerutscht bin, weil ich halt in einer alten Muster zurückverfahren bin und auch dieses Problem hatte, dass ich immer viel zu viel mit Computern gemacht hatte, dass ich eigentlich gar nicht wollte, dann was komplett anderes studiert habe und am Ende dann wieder da gelandet bin, wo ich angefangen habe.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine Informatik, so eine Sucht, dass in die man reinrutscht, man kommt nie wieder von los. Jetzt bitte ich mal um ein Zeichen. Also David, du bist noch in der Ausbildung, richtig?
Genau.
Planst du sie fertig zu machen? Aha, okay, gut, reden wir später noch drüber. Von den anderen Anwesenden, wer hat dein Studium beendet?
Ich habe halt ein anderes Studium beendet.
Also hast du das nicht beendet?
Ich habe dieses Studium nicht beendet. Ich bin gelernter Betriebswirt.
Ich habe ja auch Informatik studiert. Eine Geschichte, die ich gerne erzählen, ist, dass ich nicht nur Programmieren gelernt habe. Und ich bin trotzdem durchgegangen.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz typisches Phänomen. Informatik studieren und Programmieren können, das berührt sich, aber das ist weder erforderlich, noch ausreichend.
Na ja, I beg to differ. Also jein, ich bin jetzt durchgekommen, ohne programmieren zu können. Aber ich hatte schon ganz deutlich einen Punkt, in meinem Schuh, das ist jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahrchen her, aber es gab einen deutlichen Punkt, wo in den Hausaufgaben vorausgesetzt wurde, dass ich programmieren kann. Also wo gesagt wurde, hier, da ist dieser Software-Fußballspieler, programmiere dem mal ein Wahrnehmungsapparat in C, weil weiß ja jeder, wie man C programmiert. Außer mir anscheinend.
Ja, man kommt es aber nicht beigebracht. Wahrscheinlich auch eine Sache, die eher im deutschen Informatikstudium zu finden ist. Also ich habe den Eindruck, dass zum Beispiel Computer Science in den USA da auch anders aufgebaut ist. Bei uns gibt es ja diese klassische Fachhochschule versus Universitätseinteilung an der Fachhochschule. Da lernst du ein Programm, in der gibt es eine C-Vorlesung, da klärt dir das ein Pointer und das ein Integer. Und wenn man das da macht, dann crash das Programm und das ist blöd. Und im Informatikstudium, also im Universitätsstudium, ist es eher so, dass du gesagt hast, naja, kannst du auch lernen. Das ist bestimmt auch nützlich und so ein bisschen muss man das auch können. Aber halt, du schreibst auch keinen großen Programm. Du schreibst irgendwie kleine Programme für deine Hausarbeiten.
Ich begleite mich ein bisschen. An der TU machen wir es tatsächlich so, dass wir in den Studiengängen so Basisprogrammiervorlesungen haben, die so Programmieren beibringen und dabei noch Algorithmen beibringen. Das heißt, man kriegt schon Java irgendwie beigebracht als Elektrotechniker und so einen Basis C-Kurs, den wir auch im Fachgebiet machen, der aber halt Algorithmen macht. Man lernt aber nicht, dass Programmieren so wie man es für eine Firma bräuchte oder so wie man es als Programmierer bräuchte. Sondern man lernt Programmieren als Werkzeug, um damit Algorithmen programmieren zu können. Und ja, es sind halt alles kleine Programme und man lernt nicht so Softwareentwicklung, wie man es für den Beruf Softwareentwickler oder Programmierer bräuchte.
Eins wollte ich aber noch loswerden. Du erwähntest das irgendwie, dass man nur ein echter Hacker sei mit einem abgebrochenen Informatikstudium. Da muss ich gleich mal widersprechen. Also ich kenne Leute, deren höchster Abschluss, gute Hacker, wirklich spitzen Leute, deren höchster Abschluss ist ein Realschulabschluss. Und es gibt auch gute Hacker, deren höchster Abschluss ist ein Doktor der Informatik mit demnächst auch einer Professur. Also das scheint nicht zu korrelieren. Das ist ein Skillsetting, das kann man lernen oder auch nicht, für Hacker sein.
Man lernt kein Programmieren, aber auch nicht so richtig, dass man es in praktischer Anwendung hat. Für jemanden, der noch gar keine Erfahrung hat, was genau lernt man denn in einem Informatikstudium? Es ist ja oft dieses anscheinend, was mit Computern? Deswegen studiere ich das jetzt. Was erwartet einen denn da an der Uni? Wir machen ja nachher noch die einzelnen Fachbereiche, was die bedeuten. Aber was ist denn die Aufgabe eines Informatikstudiums?
Vielleicht fangen wir mal damit an, was ist die Aufgabe eines Studiums? Die Aufgabe eines Studiums ist es, den Geist zu bilden und den Charakter zu formen.
Das mag ja sozusagen in einer idealisierten humanistischen Welt zu gelten. Aber wenn ich in Zeitungen lese, was Politiker oder Wirtschaftsleute über Studien sagen, dann sagen sie mal, naja, die Leute, die aus der Uni fallen, die sind nicht verwendbar.
Na ja, die erwarten halt sozusagen fertig für ein bestimmtes schmales Fachgebiet ausgebildete Leute. Und das kriegen sie möglicherweise nicht. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, wer Programmierer wird, also viele davon haben studiert, aber viele haben dann auch so was wie Physik studiert oder Mathematik oder Geologie oder Astronomie oder auch Geisteswissenschaften. Die Kernfähigkeit, die einem beim Studium vermittelt wird und auch vermittelt werden sollte, meiner Meinung nach, ist nämlich die, selbst tätig zu denken, sich selbst tätig Themen zu erarbeiten. So hast du ein Problem und jetzt hast du nicht einen Katalog von möglichen Lösungen und wenn du die Lösungen nie gelernt hast, dann stehst du da, sondern Literatur erarbeiten, sich selbst tätig Gedanken machen, selber denken, Sachen zu entwickeln, das ist doch die Aufgabe eines Studiums.
Na gut, aber das ist die Aufgabe ja jeden Studium. Was ist denn jetzt die Aufgabe des Informatikstudiums?
Da muss man tatsächlich auf die konkreten Inhalte eingehen. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es heute ist. Mein Studium ist 20 Jahre her. Da gab es im Grundstudium dann so Sachen wie Mathematik und Logik für Informatiker, Programmiergrundschluss, Elektronik.
Dann lass mich anders formulieren. Was ist sozusagen der, der fertig Informatik studiert hat? Was kann der?
Du solltest Probleme als solche erkennen können. Du solltest einschätzen können, wie man ein Problem aus der Realität in Software abbilden und lösen kann und neue Lösungen finden und nicht nur vorhandene zusammenstecken. Also du solltest ein Programm entwickeln können, aus sich heraus, aus dir heraus, um ein Problem zu lösen, was in der Realität besteht. Sowas wie...
Aber das hört sich jetzt schon an, wie ich muss programmieren und Software entwickeln können.
Das ist hilfreich. Allerdings de facto nicht notwendig, um Abschluss in Informatikstudien zu kriegen, was mich auch immer wieder verblüfft. Man muss nicht besonders gut sein, wenn man dafür vielleicht auch andere Qualitäten hat. Ein Informatikstudien beschäftigt sich zum Beispiel mit so Sachen wie der Komplexitätsanalyse von Algorithmen. Und das ist etwas, was in der Praxis des Programmierers zu 99% nicht vorkommt. Das ist so irgendwie, du musst halt ein Problem... Also praktische Programmierung sieht heutzutage so aus. Du musst ein Problem lösen. Dann googlst du erstmal, was es dafür Libraries gibt. Dann guckst du auf Stack Overflow nach, wie man irgendwie eine triviale Anwendung dafür schreibt. Und dann pastet man das zusammen und dann probiert man das aus. Und wenn man dann gründlich ist, dann schreibt man einfach seine Test Cases und macht eine Performanceanalyse. Und in der Regel ist es schnell genug. Und dann ist man fertig. Und ob das jetzt irgendwie mit O von N mal log N oder O von N mal log N in den Quadrat wird.
Dazu kommen wir später noch.
Also ich sehe halt das Problem, das Andreas gerade anspricht, als das müsste eigentlich eher so sein. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass das Informatikstudium zumindestens, so wie ich es bisher in Deutschland erlebt habe, inzwischen davon weggegangen ist, Menschen dazu zu bringen, dass sie am Ende vom Studium, wenn sie den Abschluss haben, Probleme lösen können. Und wirklich diese eigenständige Transferleistung mehr als Dinge, die da sind, zusammenzustecken, wirklich treffen können. Das ist etwas, was so ein bisschen aus unserem Curricula rausgetropfelt ist.
Also das wäre schön, wenn das noch so wäre. Und das wird auch angestrebt. Aber dazu muss sich der einzelne Studierende schon bemühen, das auch zu wollen. Du kommst durchs Studium, ohne das zu können. Aber eigentlich ist das der Anspruch des Studiums, das den Leuten beizubringen.
Aber gleichzeitig passiert das nicht.
Du bist halt auch eigenverantwortlich. Also im Studium heißt auch, du musst eigenverantwortlich dich in Dinge einarbeiten.
Aber das ist ja leicht gesagt, gerade jetzt nach Bologna irgendwie zu sagen, also hier ist das Studium. Und in diesem Studium bringen wir dir bestimmte Sachen nicht bei, erwarten aber von dir, dass du die einarbeitest. Aber gleichzeitig hast du einen vollen Stundenplan und musst möglicherweise noch dafür sorgen, dass es Geld gibt. Also dann fangen wir vielleicht nochmal ganz anders an. Wenn man heutzutage Informatik studieren möchte, was sollte man dann mitbringen? Also was sollte man schon können? Und was sollte man auf dem Konto haben oder an Vorraussetzungen mitbringen? Falls man sich jetzt gerade mit dem Gedanken trägt.
Was man auf jeden Fall lernen wird, ist Frusttoleranz. Nee, nee, was soll man mitbringen? Es hilft, das mitzubringen. Weil das ist eine Vorraussetzung, oder das ist was, was in der Informatik glücklich hilft. Du wirst immer wieder vor Problemen stehen, wo du Stunden brauchst, um es zu verstehen. Das wird halt immer wieder passieren, auch beim Programmieren. Was sollte man mitbringen? Eine gewisse Fähigkeit oder den Wunsch, es zu lernen, logisch zu denken. Und es hilft, algorithmisch denken zu können. Das heißt, Abläufe als Aneinanderreihung von, wie erklärt man das, von Vorgängen aufzufassen. Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel zu einem Amt gehe, dann sehe ich wieder Formulare in welcher Reihenfolge von wem zu wem gehen. Das ist ein Vorgang. Den kann man in Software abbilden. Als Informatiker stellt man irgendwann fest, dass man diese ganzen Vorgänge, die man irgendwo beobachtet im Alltag, im Hinterkopf so ein bisschen schon in Algorithmen umsetzt. Das passiert einfach unwillkürlich.
Tobias, was würdest du sagen?
Ich denke, dass es schwierig ist und dass man definitiv irgendeine Vorstellung davon braucht, was man irgendwie mit sich selber so ein bisschen anfangen möchte am Ende. Weil gerade dieser Zeitraum so ein bisschen aus diesem Studium rausgefallen ist. Das heißt, irgendwie so ein Plan, so eine Perspektive, da möchte ich hin.
Okay, man sollte am besten schon wissen, was man damit machen möchte am Ende.
Nicht unbedingt, das kann auch eher so in die Richtung Traum gehen, aber das ist was ganz, ganz Wichtiges, um gerade diese Frusttoleranz auch zu haben.
Okay, das muss man Spaß machen. Ich glaube, man sollte der Mathematik nicht abgeneigt sein. Das hilft, wenn man Mathe spannend findet. Also insbesondere diskrete Mathematik und Algebra.
Was ist diskrete Mathematik?
Kannst du dich erinnern an die Geschichten mit den Kurven und den Ableitungen? Das nicht.
Sondern?
Das andere. Polynom-Division.
Grafen.
Grafentheorie.
Kannst du es so erklären, dass jemand, der noch nicht weiß, also quasi wenn du mir jetzt Grafentheorie sagst, dann weiß ich grob, worum es geht, aber jemand, der jetzt vom...
Ein Routenplaner vom Matigationssystem. Ich habe einen Punkt, von dem ich starte, einen Punkt, wo ich hin möchte. Dazwischen gibt es Straßen und Kreuzungen. Und ich suche einen Weg von A nach B.
Was hat das mit der Mathematik zu tun?
Das ist Grafentheorie.
Das ist diskrete Mathematik?
Das ist diskrete Mathematik. Das mit den Integralen und den Ableitungen, das ist die kontinuierliche Mathematik, sozusagen das andere Feld.
Lass mich die Frage anstellen. Leistungskurs oder kriegt Grundkurs auch im Abi?
Das ist nicht so wichtig. Man kriegt da eh nicht vermittelt, was man braucht. Hauptsache es macht einem Spaß.
Tatsächlich fängt das Studium bei der Mathematik in der Informatik bei Null an. Und man lernt sowieso alles nochmal.
Also wenn man in seinem Leben schon mal vorher einen Beweis gesehen hat, und am besten einen induktiven Beweis, das sind natürlich super voraussetzungen.
Aber jetzt habt ihr alle drei, habt ihr so Fach, mehr oder weniger so Fachdinger gesagt. Was ist denn, was muss ich denn als Mensch auch mitbringen? Also muss ich zum Beispiel ein dickes Bankkonto mitbringen, weil ich eh keine Zeit mehr habe, nebenbei was anderes zu machen. Muss ich schon vorher programmieren können besser? Oder kann ich das doch irgendwie nebenbei lernen?
Du musst nicht programmieren können, wenn du dafür... also wenn es okay für dich ist, nicht in einer Regelstudienzeit zu studieren, ist es auch überhaupt kein Problem, nebenbei zu jobben. Man muss dann nur auffassen, dass man nicht zu viel jobbt und das Studium abbricht, weil man ja Geld verdient. Und zwar genug Geld.
Ja, ansonsten ist es nicht so furchtbar teuer als Studium, zumal wir ja noch keine amprekantischen Verhältnisse haben, wo man 50.000 Dollar im Semester bezahlt.
Was wichtiger ist vielleicht wirklich zu gucken, welche Stadt man spannend findet und ob man an einer Riesenuniversität studieren möchte, wie in Berlin an der TU oder FU oder nach Chemnitz geht, wo es relativ kuschelig und klein ist, sollte man sich auch mal irgendwie vorher angeguckt haben, einfach mal hingefahren sein, um zu sehen, wo man sich wohler fühlt. Die einen mögen es lieber, wenn sie so ein bisschen anonym im Stroh mitschwimmen können, und die anderen finden es schöner, wenn die Profs alle ihre Studenten kennen und man so ein persönliches Verhältnis hat.
Okay, können wir nachher vielleicht auch nochmal genau darüber sprechen. Ich würde von dir nochmal wissen wollen, was sind die Voraussetzungen, die man als Fachinformatiker mitbringen muss?
Die Voraussetzungen, also im Grunde für die Ausbildung fast nichts.
Außer ein einigermaßen brauchbares Zeugnis, oder?
Das gar nicht mal. Also, viele Unternehmen, es kommt drauf an, die Ausbildung hängt sehr davon ab, wie das Unternehmen ist und wie professionell das Unternehmen arbeitet und was es macht. Viele Unternehmen schauen sehr aufs Zeugnis, aber andere überhaupt nicht. Ich zum Beispiel musste in meinem Bewerbungsvorgang kein einziges Zeugnis einreichen. Ich musste tatsächlich dann der Berufsschule eins geben, aber nur um zu zeigen, dass ich den Realschulabschluss habe. Aber es kommt sehr darauf an, wo man wohnt. Wenn man in Berlin eine Ausbildung sucht, dann ist das Zeugnis, denke ich, relativ egal. Eher sollte man Interesse mitbringen. Also wenn ich mich in meiner Berufsschulklasse umschaue, dann haben die meisten Leute privat eher weniger Interesse an der Informatik. Vielleicht bauen sie sich ihren eigenen Gaming-Rechner zusammen, aber darüber hinaus nicht viel. Aber ich glaube, wenn man da richtig erfolgreich sein will, dann sollte man da schon, oder wenn man es wirklich lernen will, sollte man da auch von sich aus Interesse mitbringen.
Jetzt, also erschließt sich mir gerade erst, ich hatte erst gedacht, so Fachinformatiker, das ist vielleicht so was Ähnliches wie sozusagen so technische Hochschule oder Fachhochschule, nur sozusagen ein bisschen schneller. Aber das scheint ja wirklich so, also im Prinzip wie eine Handwerksausbildung zu sein. Also ich gehe zu einer Firma und lerne dort im Prinzip, was die machen. Jetzt frage ich mich, wenn ich jetzt also Tischler lerne, dann gehe ich zu einem Tischlermeister, lerne das da und kann dann mit Holz umgehen. Wie ist denn das? Was bist du denn, wenn du jetzt deine, wenn du das da, also wir wissen noch nicht, ob du das fertig machen wirst. Aber wenn das fertig ist, was sozusagen ist das Ende? Kannst du schon jetzt ganz klar sagen, wer du sein wirst, wenn du diese Ausbildung zu Ende bringst?
Also in der Ausbildungsordnung steht drin, was man können muss und es wird dann auch in der Prüfung abgefragt. Aber die Ausbildungsordnung ist älter als ich.
Ich glaube, das wurde so 1995 oder 1994 eingeführt, die Ausbildung.
Ich glaube, die aktuelle Ausbildungsordnung ist von 1997. Ich bin 1998 geboren. Aber die ist zum Glück sehr allgemein gehalten. Aber da kommt kein einziges Mal das Wort Internet drin vor.
Aber das heißt auch sozusagen, dass du in der Ausbildung all das lernst, was die Firma braucht. Also die baut dich quasi zu jemandem, den sie dann benutzen oder anstellen kann.
Also das ist das duale Ausbildungsprinzip. Das heißt, bei mir ist es so, ich gehe zwei Wochen in den Betrieb, eine Woche in die Berufsschule. Und die Idee dahinter ist, dass ich im Betrieb das praktische Arbeiten lerne, was dann halt sehr betriebsspezifisch ist. Und in der Berufsschule das Allgemeine. Das unterscheidet sich ziemlich. Also ich bin bei einem Unternehmen, das so relativ großes Haus Ding macht. Cloud, Zeug, Bingo. Und meine Mitspieler sind meist bei so kleinen Systemhäusern oder so Betriebe, in denen unter zehn Leute arbeiten. Und das unterscheidet sich sehr. Also was ich halt, ich habe zum Beispiel in meiner ersten Woche in der Ausbildung schon an großen Kunden-Webseiten rumgebastelt. Was vielleicht auch eher daran liegt, dass ich halt schon relativ weit war.
Aber lass mich fragen, wenn du fertig bist und diese Jahre zugebracht hast in dieser Firma, ist das was du kannst? Kannst du dann auch theoretisch woanders hingehen oder müsstest du da wieder von Null anfangen? Oder wird das dann dadurch, dass du bei einer Firma bist, ist das dann so zugespitzt, dass du eigentlich immer noch mal extra Aufwand betreiben musst, wenn du woanders hingehst?
Also eigentlich bringt einem die Berufsschule alles bei, was man für den Schein auf dem steht, Fachinformatiker braucht. Das sind dann Sachen wie kann einen Drucker anschließen und eine Fritz-Box.
Es gibt ja auch drei oder vier verschiedene. Es gibt den Fachinformatik 2.0, Anwendungsentwicklung und Systemintegration. Wir hatten in einer Firma, in der ich gearbeitet habe, auch Auszubildende. Die mussten alles machen, von Windows-Updates, Grafikkartentreiber installieren, Drucker anschließen, aber auch Server warten und Fallserver konfigurieren.
Ich kriege noch kein festes Bild von diesem Berufsbild. Das Berufsbild ist noch nicht fest, weil was du jetzt erzählst, das klingt so wie, das ist wirklich der Typ, wo man hingeht und fragt, kannst du mal meinen Drucker irgendwie, der macht gelbe, komische Punkte, was ist denn da los? Aber was David du erzählst, das ist ja eher dieses, ich mache sozusagen das in der praktischen Anwendung, wo man eigentlich klischeehaft denkt, das findet im Informatiksturm statt, ich programmiere Systeme.
Das ist so eine schwierige Sache. Es hängt halt echt stark vom Unternehmen ab. Ich zum Beispiel hab mir früher, TM gesagt, ich will niemals eine Ausbildung machen, weil ich die Inhalte einfach nicht interessant finde. Aber das lag einfach daran, dass es in meiner Heimatstadt keine Unternehmen gab, bei denen ich interessant fand, was die machen. Es hängt echt extrem stark vom Unternehmen ab. Und deshalb, wenn man eine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker machen will, muss man da picky sein und wirklich drauf achten. Sonst landet man am Ende da und schließt Drucker an. Für einen ist es super und genau das, was sie wollen, aber für die anderen ist es total langweilig und unterfordert.
Beim Fachinformatiker ist es fast schon egal, ist die Ausbildung fast schon egal, sondern viel, viel wichtiger ist, wo man landet.
Genau.
Diese Frage will ich nachher stellen, wie das bei der Uni ist. Vorher gibt es aber ein kleines Stück Musik. Musik von Stein van Waageren, Interactive Dream Device heißt der Track und so heißt auch das gleichnamige Album. Wir sind hier beim Chaos Radio, wo wir heute nicht nur ganz ausführlich über das Informatikstudium sprechen, sondern wo es natürlich auch Nerd News gibt. Geschrieben wurden die dieses Mal von Mo und präsentiert werden sie von Helena Ahr.
Adblocker verstoßen nicht gegen geltendes Recht. Adblocker sind gesetzeskonform. Das hat das Oberlandesgericht München in drei Verfahren entschieden, mit denen drei Medienunternehmen den Vertrieb von Adblock Plus stoppen wollten. Kläger sind die Süddeutsche Zeitung, ein Werbevermarkter und die Sendergruppe ProSiebenSat1. Sie werfen dem Softwarehersteller Marktmissbrauch, Urheberrechtsverstöße und Aushöhlung der Pressefreiheit vor. Sie verloren das Verfahren in allen Punkten. Es wird damit gerechnet, dass sie vor den Bundesgerichtshof ziehen. Regulierungsbehörde geht gegen My Friend Kyla vor. Die Bundesnetzagentur geht gegen den Vertrieb von sendefähigem Spielzeug vor, bei dem also Audiosignale an den Hersteller gesendet werden können. Das Chaosradio berichtete in der Vergangenheit über die Abhörgruppe Kyla. Die Regulierungsbehörde recherchiert nach Angaben der Bundesregierung ständig nach verbotenen Sendeanlagen. Zudem gilt die Netzagentur Hinweisen von Verbrauchern nach. Bis Mitte August hat die Behörde rund 160 Verfahren eingeleitet und etwa 400 Angebote löschen lassen. Cyber im Wahlkampf. Bundesinnenminister Thomas de Maizière von der CDU hat die Einrichtung einer ehrenamtlichen Cyberfeuerwehr angeregt. Auf einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung stellte er die Frage, wen ruft man eigentlich an, wenn die Cyberanlage ausfällt? Eine Cyberfeuerwehr könne eine Chance sein, junge Menschen zu begeistern. Sie könnten sich sagen, ich hecke auch sonst gerne, dann heck ich mal für die Guten.
Wo ist mein Blaulicht, wo ist mein Blaulicht?
Da ist schon blau.
Aber krass, also Cyberfeuerwehr Berlin Mitte, Marienstraße 11, könnt gerne hier vorbeikommen und auch bereit erklären, wir senden hier das Chaosradio live. Es geht heute nur ums Informatikstudium. Eigentlich nicht, eigentlich geht es sozusagen um den Weg.
Das Berufsbild des Informatikers.
Ja, irgendwie so in der Richtung. Also wir haben schon festgestellt, es gibt den universitären Weg und den des Fachinformatikers, dass es eine Berufsausbildung ist und da haben wir festgestellt, dass der Teil, der sozusagen berufsschulmäßig stattfindet, eigentlich egal ist und das ganz extrem darauf ankommt, bei welcher Firma man das macht, weil daraus erschließt sich dann, wie viel man da lernt und was man alles kann und wie viel Spaß es wahrscheinlich auch macht.
Gibt ja auch Sportunterricht.
Ehrlich?
Ja und es zählt so ein Prozent in die Abschlussnote.
Der Ausbilder der Firma muss zum Elternabend.
Das würde ich noch so sagen unter seltsames Ritual abtun, aber Sportunterricht? Gibt es auch Gartenkunde? Werken?
Leider nicht.
Egal. Jetzt haben wir schon gehört, es ist ganz wichtig, welche Firma man sich als Fachinformatiker ausbilden lässt. Wie ist das denn bei der Uni? Da gibt es ja, in manchen Fällen gibt es so, ja, also wenn du keine Ahnung, Medizin studieren willst, musst du unbedingt nach, weiß ich nicht, Leipzig, weil da die Skalpelle besonders spitz sind. Wissen Sie, bei Informatik ist es da, also, Montags hat es vorhin schon gesagt, irgendwie man muss gucken, welche Stadt man will. Ist das wirklich der einzige Auswahlkriterium, dass man sagt, ich möchte sozusagen eine Stadt, die mir liegt, oder gibt es auch guten und schlechter Ruf?
Es gibt guten und schlechter Ruf, es gibt vor allem ganz unterschiedliche Ausrichtungen und Aufhänger. Ich komme aus Marburg, da ist die Informatik ein Teil der Mathematik zum Beispiel. Das heißt, da ist mein Eindruck her, dass es halt so was völlig trockenes und ganz theoretisches und mathematisches ist, weil da ist die Informatik entstanden aus dem Fachgebiet Mathematik und entsprechend hat die dann sehr, sehr stark Mathematikbezug. An der TU ist es technischer, auch wenn jetzt der Name Technische Universität nicht unbedingt eine Garantie dafür ist, dass es technisch ist. Aber es gibt halt die technische Informatik, es gibt die Informatik, es gibt die Elektrotechnik und die überschneiden sich inhaltlich auch alle so ein bisschen. Die Elektrotechniker lernen auch ein bisschen Informatik und die technischen Informatiker lernen aus beiden Inhalten. Jede Uni hat so ein bisschen auch eine andere Ausrichtung. Es gibt auch noch Wirtschaftsinformatiker. Das heißt, es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Studiengänge, die andere Schwerpunkte haben vom Inhaltklärer und was sie dabei bringen wollen.
Also okay, gut, danke, aber das kann ich ja sozusagen noch lesen. Also ich kann mir den Lehrplan angucken und dann sehe ich, was da beschrieben wird. Das heißt, das kann ich vorwegnehmen. Aber ich meinte jetzt eher, was den Ruf angeht. Also gesetzlichen Fall, ich will jetzt, weiß ich nicht, Wirtschaftsinformatik studieren, da gibt es wahrscheinlich mehrere Unis, die das anbieten. Und ist dann sozusagen, also ist das ein so difíciles Thema? Natürlich gibt es immer gute und schlechte Lehrende. Aber ist es da sozusagen auch von der Qualitätsstufe her wichtig? Weil es ist ja manchmal, es ist ja so, okay, der hat den Abschluss von der und der Uni, das ist total super krass.
Also ich würde einfach mal behaupten, dass es in Deutschland relativ egal ist, in welcher Uni man letztlich seinen Abschluss macht. Und es ist wirklich viel mehr darauf ankommt, ob man sich in der Stadt wohlfühlt, ob man sich an der Uni wohlfühlt, ob man sich mit dem Lehrkonzept an der Uni wohlfühlt, welche Menschen da lernen, ob man einen Zugang zu der Art von Pädagogik, die gerade an der Uni geführt wird hat. Und ob man da vielleicht andere soziale Rahmenbedingungen hat, ob einem die Größe der Uni zusagt, Mutrax hatte das ja eben schon relativ deutlich ausgeführt. Das sind glaube ich in Deutschland eher so die wichtigen Dinge. Wir sind meilenweit entfernt von einem System wie in den USA, wo man sagt, naja, okay, State College, kannst du ja eigentlich auch sparen. Oder halt University of California, okay, total super.
Wie ist es denn, dass man da überhaupt hinkommt? Also ist das zugangsbeschränkt, oder kann man sich einfach im Prinzip überall einschreiben und auch die Uni wechseln, wenn man will?
Also wir haben ja gerade Fachkräftemangel.
Ja, Moment mal, ich hab doch gerade gelernt, dass die nicht an der Uni ausgebildet sind. Okay, also...
Also in der Praxis ist es an der TU, glaube ich, momentan gar nicht NC-beschränkt. Aber viel wichtiger ist noch, ob man an die FH gehen möchte oder ob man an die Uni gehen möchte. Die Entscheidung ist halt wichtiger, die man sich stellen muss. In der FH ist es halt eher praktisch orientiert von der Ausbildung.
Lernt man da programmieren?
Da lernt man auch programmieren, genau. Und an der Uni ist es schon traditionell mehr so die Ausrichtung Richtung Wissenschaft. Das heißt, man soll eigentlich oder die Idee ist eigentlich, dass ein ausgebildeter Informatiker von der Uni ein Wissenschaftler ist, der wissenschaftlich arbeitet und neue Problemstellungen findet und löst selbstständig und sich auch in neue Themen einarbeitet und neues Wissen schafft und nicht nur vorhandenes Wissen anwendet.
Also warte mal, dann könnte man zu sagen, ein Unterteil machen, Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker ist extrem firmenabhängig und zugespitzt, was ich da lerne. Fachhochschule ist, ich lerne das schon in einer abstrakten Art mehr oder weniger. Also ich lerne die Werkzeuge, aber das in der praktischen Anwendbarkeit. Und normale Uni ist Elfenbeinturm.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Also aus der Praxis kenne ich halt so, wir hatten Fachinformatiker, das waren die Administratoren von Admin-Team. Dann hatten wir Programmierer, das waren normalerweise FH-Studenten oder abgeschlossenes FH-Studium. Die haben eben dann programmiert, die haben die Systeme entwickelt. Und die Abteilungsleiter, die Leads, die die Vorgaben gemacht haben, die die Systeme ausgedacht haben. Die, die sich halt kreativ ausgedacht haben, wie das System mal funktionieren soll, das waren halt Hochschul-Adminen.
Also zynisch aus der Praxis könnte man zusammenfassen, die von der Uni kommen können am wenigsten, deswegen wären sie die Chefs.
Nein, die lernen halt mehr die Konzepte und mehr so den groben Überblick. Das ist aber abstrakt, also das muss nicht so sein.
Okay, dann anders gefragt. Also Fachinformatik bin ich an der Firma, da kann ich bestimmte Sachen erfahren, kann ich dann wirklich programmieren. Was so Uni, da soll ich in den Wissenschaftsbetrieb ja gehen. Das ist ja so irgendwie, das endet ja bei der Professur und dann ist es irgendwie so, ein Prof hat irgendwie sechs potentielle Nachfolge, nur einer kann die Stelle kriegen. Also da ist ja absehbar, dass man das nicht auf Dauer macht.
Da wird man Manager.
Aber das ist jetzt genau die Frage. Wenn ich mit der Uni fertig bin, werde ich dann sofort Manager? Hier Uniabschluss, ich möchte jetzt Chef sein. Andreas, wie ist das?
Na eher unwahrscheinlich.
Ach gut, was mache ich denn dann mit meinem Informatikstudium?
Ja, also so ein Informatikstudium ist etwas, wo man die Frage, wofür brauche ich das denn später nicht unbedingt stellen darf. Also ein Fachhochschulstudium hat den Anspruch, dass das, was man da lernt, tatsächlich relevant ist und Hand und Fuß hat und irgendwie benutzbar ist. Und in einem Informatikstudium, da lernt man zwar auch lauter nützliche Sachen, aber zum Beispiel gibt es da einen Kurs über, wie eine CPU funktioniert. Und dann fragst du dich, wie viel Prozent der Leute, die ein Informatikstudium abschließen, die sein hinterher CPUs. Das ist fast keiner. Oder compiler bauen oder 3D-Grafik machen, dann vielleicht schon ein paar mehr Leute. Da geht es also auch schon um die Bewusstseinserweiterung, was es sonst noch so alles gibt und wie die großen Zusammenhänge sind.
Aber das ist ja auch gut, weil dann kommt man zu sagen, die Spitze ist ja dann in der Wissenschaft, die müsste das ja auch alles wissen. Aber was mache ich denn jetzt, wenn ich da genau nicht lande? Also was mache ich nach dem Studium?
Na du wirst halt auch Programmierer oder Manager oder Projektleiter oder...
Aber man muss das erst noch lernen, weil an der Uni hat es mir ja keiner beigebracht.
Also typischerweise bringst du das ja selber bei. Du lernst an der Uni das Programmieren so Basistypisch und in deiner Freizeit hängst du dich halt rein und lernst das dann, wie es richtig geht. Oder du hast einen Job nebenbei und lernst das halt dann im Job.
Also wenn du heutzutage in eine Firma kommst, ein Vorstellungsgespräch, dann gucken die sich dein CV an und da steht dann drauf, hast du was studiert oder nicht? Und irgendwie so, ja, einen schönen Abschluss haben sie. Was haben sie denn so für Open-Source-Projekte gemacht? Haben sie einen GitHub-Account? Kann man sich das mal angucken, was sie getan haben? Das wollen sie sehen. Also wenn du tatsächlich Codeschreiben willst in deinem Beruf, dann ist es hilfreich, zu zeigen zu können, dass du es auch kannst und getan hast. Und die Uni, die vermittelt einem, glaube ich, die Möglichkeit, Dinge zu tun, die man nicht unbedingt durch Stack Exchange zusammenpasten, gelöst bekommt. Wo man vielleicht einen Schritt weiter denken muss und überhaupt den Blick dafür haben muss, dass bestimmte Probleme auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise lösbar sind. Da muss man hingehen und sagen, das sieht so aus, als könnte man das jetzt in einen Graphen übersetzen und da gibt es diesen Tollner, wo man es kennengelernt hat und dann kann man das alles komplett anders machen. Das ist das, wo sich dann so ein Studium auch auszahlt am Ende.
Aber ich stelle mir jetzt wirklich gerade die Frage, weil das wiederholt jetzt schon gesagt wurde, also man lernt in einem Studium, sagen diese theoretischen abstrakten Konzepte, dann muss man sich selber noch das Programmieren beibringen. Da bleibt ja tatsächlich keine Zeit, um noch zusätzlich Geld zu verdienen. Das heißt, man ist entweder privilegiert und hat die Kohle oder, und das ist jetzt die zweite Frage, die ich stellen möchte, weil du jetzt auch gesagt hast, man kann ja dann sozusagen schon als Nebenjob auch im Programmieren arbeiten. Aber wiederum, wenn ich jetzt anfange und das noch nicht kann und mir das gerade selber beibringen muss, also wie schnell geht das denn, dass ich das auch als Job machen kann, um das zu verbinden sozusagen, dieses ich lerne das, aber gleichzeitig arbeite ich da schon mal. Ich meine, es gibt auch nur begrenzte wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiter und Hilfskräfte in der Uni.
Das ist immer schwer zu sagen, das ist auch die Frage, wie gut du das können willst. Also es gibt ja diesen Spruch von irgendwie...
Na gut, nee, gut genug, um Geld zu verdienen. Das ist ja der Punkt.
Da gut genug, um Geld zu verdienen, das ist... Das geht schnell. Also wenn du dich ein Jahr in irgendwas reinhängst, dann kannst du das ja so... Also für schätzenden ein, zwei Jahren bist du auf einem Level, wo du halt mal als Systemadministrator was tun kannst, einen Rechner warten kannst.
Also ein, zwei Jahre nebenbei. Also wir reden davon, ich studiere und...
Ja, ja, ja, ja, so mal eine Webseite aufsetzen, das sind alles erreichbare Sachen. Und wie gesagt, bei mir ist auch 20 Jahre her, aber ich hab mir auch mein Studium damit verdient, dass ich nebenbei Webseiten administriert habe und selber aufgesetzt und...
Ist das denn so, dass sozusagen heute... Also das ist ja so auf einem Markt, wo händeringend diese Leute gesucht werden, dann ist es natürlich einfacher, dass man sagt, also hier, ich hab mir das, ich studiere das und ich hab mir Webseiten, ja, auch das. Also genau das zufälligerweise, bei What What Sie wollen.
Das Lustige ist halt, wenn du dieses Label hast, du studierst Informatik, dann trauen die Firmen erst mal alles zu, weil du bist der Informatikstudent.
Das ist der eigentliche Zweck des Studiums, verstehe.
Ich hab zum Beispiel sechs Jahre oder sieben Jahre als Admin gearbeitet neben dem Studium und hab halt in der Firma irgendwie mitgearbeitet und hab halt da irgendwie Server mit gewartet.
Und du hast als Admin gearbeitet, also da angefangen hast. Konntest du das da schon?
Ja, da konnte ich schon, weil ich es mir als Schüler schon beigebracht hab, so dieses Linux Zeug. Aber worauf ich nachher auswollte, diese theoretischen Sachen, wie eine CPU funktioniert und so weiter, die helfen dann Informatiker wieder in der Praxis, zum Beispiel wenn du irgendein cloudbasiertes Server-System baut, weil halt diese ganzen Techniken, die man da in der CPU, in dem Zwischenspeicher, in dem Cache einsetzt, da auch wieder anwenden kann. Oder Betriebssysteme. Man lernt als Informatiker, wie funktioniert ein Betriebssystem in und sollte in der Lage sein, selber auch eins zu schreiben. Und das kann man abstrakt wieder anwenden auf andere Systeme. Also kleine Betriebssysteme, jetzt nicht so was wie Linux oder Windows. Aber für so einen kleinen Mikrocontroller möchte man vielleicht auch ein Betriebssystem drauf haben, um mehrere Sachen parallel zu machen. Und diese Konzepte kann man natürlich auch wieder auf andere große Systeme übersetzen und anwenden. Und das ist halt was, was typischerweise so ein Systemarchitekt als Informatiker macht. Diese Konzepte sich ausdenken.
Jetzt gibt es ja trotzdem dieses Klischeebild vom abgebrochenen Informatikstudium.
Ich glaube, das hat was mit enttäuschten Erwartungen über die Inhalte des Studiums zu tun. Konkret bei mir war es einfach so, es war 1997, der große Internetboom ging los. Also da, wo ich Systemanonstrator für Webseiten war, das war die erste kommerzielle Webseite in Deutschland. Und die war super spannend und ich habe da quasi bei den Jobs nebenbei mehr gelernt als an der Uni. Also ich bin in die Vorlesung gegangen, dann habe ich mir die Hauptstudiumsvorlesung gesucht, die ich spannend fand über neuronale Netze, Compilerbau, 3D-Grafik und dann hatte ich aber meinen Grundstuhl noch nicht mehr fertig. Und dann stand ich davor, naja, ich muss jetzt noch so viele Scheine machen, mit Dingen, die mich nicht interessieren. Auf der anderen Seite könnte ich da auch Vollzeit bei den Leuten arbeiten, von denen ich viel mehr lerne. Und das ist dann der Moment, wo ich das Informatikstudio mir abgebrochen habe.
Also da würde ich gerne jetzt mal einhaken, weil dieses, naja, nebenbei Arbeiten ist gerade mal so rübergekommen, als ob das so das Ding ist, was man tun muss, um dieses Informatikstudio erfolgreich zum Ende zu bringen.
Das ist der Eindruck, den ich gerade nicht bekommen habe.
So meine gefühlte, anekdotenbasierte Erhebung im Freundes- und Bekanntenkreis ist, dass es meistens so läuft wie bei dir, Andreas, dass man halt dann irgendwie merkt, naja, das bringt mir auf irgendeiner meiner für mich im Leben wichtigen Skalen deutlich mehr, was ich gerade außerhalb der Uni mache. Und man sich dann halt irgendwann die Frage stellt, warum mache ich dann dieses Unüben überhaupt noch?
Das ist halt eine Gefahr, ja. Und ich kenne aber auch eine Menge Leute, die dann irgendwann frustriert feststellen, dass sie in einer Firma nicht mehr weiterkommen. Gerade in großen Firmen, die wollen dann oft so ein abgeschlossenes Studium haben, dass man dann Manager werden kann. Und dann versuchen sie halt krampfhaft nebenbei noch irgendwie einen Master of Business Administration zu machen, zusätzlich zum Beruf, damit sie dann in der Firma aufsteigen können. Das muss man sich halt sehr genau überlegen, was man da machen möchte.
Also ich muss auch sagen, mittlerweile bin ich einem Punkt angelangt, wo mir gewisse Inhalte dann doch fehlen. Damals, als wir Informatik studiert haben, da ging ein Beweis über die Korrektheit eines Algorithmus so. Der Prof hat irgendwie fünf Zeilen Code an die Tafel geschrieben. Und dann hat man hier ein bisschen was annotated, da ein bisschen was annotated und dann so Handwaving. Drei Stunden später war der Algorithmus korrekt bewiesen. Und heutzutage sind wir halt so weit, dass Programme von anständiger Komplexität wie so ein Compiler oder ein Betriebssystemkern voll automatisiert bewiesen werden können. Und da steckt halt viel Mathematik drin, viel Beweistechniken, die ich mir jetzt sozusagen nachträglich mühsam anarbeiten muss. Ja, so Kategorien, Theorie und solche Dinge, was man dann für funktionale Programmierung braucht. Das hätte ich jetzt schon ganz gern auch noch gewusst.
Naja, aber hätte dir das Studium das geliefert, wenn du es fertig gemacht hättest? Oder ist das eher was, was jetzt in den letzten Jahren standen ist?
Die theoretischen Grundlagen sind ja alle seit 50 Jahren bekannt. Wir sind nur mittlerweile so weit, dass man das ausreichend schnell automatisieren und durchschneiden kann.
Naja, aber deswegen die Frage, hätte dir das was gebracht, ein Studium?
Also, Kategorien, Theorie hätte es gegeben. Es hätte funktionale Programmierung gegeben. Einiges an Beweistechniken ist neu, aber vieles ist auch schon immer da gewesen und ist vielleicht auch Bestandteil der Mathematik gewesen. Also, wie man komplexere Sachverhalte in der Mathematik beweist, ist eins zu eins das, wie es jetzt in der Informatik gemacht wird für formale Methoden. Also, ja, es wäre da gewesen.
Also, Tobias gleich, aber wirst du dem jüngeren Herrn Bogh also raten, nee, mach das mal fertig?
Würde ich schon sagen, ja.
Also, ich würde behaupten, dass gerade eigentlich im Prinzip nur die Seats dann so gegen Ende des Studiums da gewesen werden, dass du halt mal so ein bisschen was davon siehst. Und gerade dieses Vertiefen, also dieses, man gräbt sich dann halt so in diese ganzen Seats, die man dann in so einem Master bekommen hat.
Na, es werden also Grundlagen und Anlegungen gegeben. Es wird so oberflächlich gestreift. Das müsstest du so mindestens mal kapiert haben, wenn du ein Studium von uns bekommst oder einen Mastertitel. Aber so wirklich in die Tiefe gehen, das musst du selber machen oder dich immer im Studium vertiefen. Weil das Studium gibt erstmal so einen groben Überblick über alles. Und dann vertiefst du dich nochmal entweder selber, in dem du einen Studiengang entsprechend hast oder mit einem Studiengebiet tief in irgendein Thema rein. Weil erstmal, wir haben so viele verschiedene Themen, Bioinformatik und diese ganzen Sachen haben wir noch gar nicht besprochen, was es da alles neben Reiheninformatik noch gibt. Allein in der Informatik sind die Themengebiete alle so groß. Und es gibt so viele verschiedene Themen, von Compilerbau über diese theoretische Informatik, über irgendwelche praktischen Sachen bis hin zu Graphen oder die ganzen Netzwerkeschichten.
Okay, wir reden gleich noch über die Unterteilung, aber Tobias, wolltest du jetzt quasi den Gegenpunkt machen und sagen, dass du eher skeptisch bist, dass tatsächlich diese Grundlagen umführen gelegt werden?
Es werden gerade nur diese ersten Anreize gegeben. Wenn du jetzt trotz allem wusstest, okay, da gibt es so Beweistheorien, ich muss mich da gerade einarbeiten, ich glaube nicht, dass das Studium zu Ende machen dir da sehr viel mehr gegeben hätte.
Es kommt darauf an, ob man halt irgendwie, vielleicht nicht mit der aktuellen Struktur, wenn man einen Master macht, aber zumindest wenn man es dann ausreizt bis zum PhD, dann hat man die Möglichkeit. Wenn man dann auch selber gestaltet ist, ist es viel einfacher, wenn du eh noch an der Uni bist, dann mal eben zu gucken, ob man nicht bei den Mathematikern noch mal was hört und sich das anguckt oder in irgendeinen Seminar geht oder in irgendeine Summer School geht und solche Geschichten. Das ist dann schon nicht mehr so, dass das Wissen aus dem Katalog kommt mit einer Prüfungsordnung, wo du irgendwie von A bis Z lernen musst, sondern du kriegst ein Angebot und es gibt die Möglichkeit. Also es gibt einerseits den zeitlichen Rahmen dafür, das zu tun, während man studiert ist und man nicht unterschätzen. Und andererseits auch das Wissensangebot, das man dann abholen kann, wenn man wirklich daran interessiert ist.
Aber die Sachen, die du jetzt machst, also irgendwie so beweisbarer Akkord und sowas, ist das, wenn man jetzt als Informatiker, der Software baut, arbeitet heutzutage Standardgeschäft? Oder bist du schon auch sozusagen, arbeitest du an einer Stelle, wo du sagst, okay, das ist schon eine höhere Ebene, und da macht man dann auch sehr die Abstrackte an Sachen?
Das ist definitiv momentan noch die Avantgarte des Programmierens. Also das machen sehr, sehr wenige Leute, aber es wird zunehmend wichtig. Es ist klar, dass irgendwie, wir bauen ja Computer, wie vor 100 Jahren irgendwie Autos in Brücken gebaut wurden. So ein Wunder, dass es nicht auseinanderfällt. Und das ist klar absehbar, dass das im Kommen ist und dass das notwendig ist.
Okay, aber das heißt auch sozusagen, also die Entscheidung, also du hast ja gesagt, vielleicht wäre Studium fertig zu machen noch die bessere Idee gewesen. Das ist aber auch eine Entscheidung, die man sozusagen da hingehen treffen kann, dass man sich überlegt, wie hoch hinaus will ich denn eigentlich. Also bin ich vielleicht zufrieden damit? Ich sag jetzt mal normal als Teil eines Teams oder auch Teamleiter vielleicht sozusagen zu arbeiten und Software zu bauen. Oder will ich an die Grenzen des Universums und möglicherweise darüber hinaus. Ich will, bevor diese halbe Stunde zu Ende geht, da noch kurz fragen. Als ich das Ganze am Anfang gefragt habe, wirst du das fertig machen? Warst ja so, haaa, mal sehen.
Wovon hängt das ab? Eine Sache bei der Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker oder generell bei Ausbildungen ist Berufsschule. Ich hab bisher in meinem ganzen Leben, glaube ich, noch nie was Positives über die Berufsschule gehört. Und es ist auch eher enttäuschend. Also die Unterrichtenden, also die LehrerInnen, sind oft schon kurz vor der Rente und haben sich auch seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr irgendwie mit dem Thema befasst und sind auch gefühlt schon seit 10 Jahren immer den gleichen Stoff am Unterrichten. Und auch so Sachen wie IPv6, dieser neue Quatsch.
Aber Berufsschule ist doch alle zwei Wochen eine Woche.
Genau.
Und das ist so frustrierend, wie lange geht die ganze Ausbildung?
Drei Jahre. Man kann auf zweieinhalb Jahre verkürzen.
Und das ist aber sozusagen so frustrierend, dass das Endziel, diesen Zettel zu haben, ist für dich nicht motivierend genug, um diese Berufsschule zu vertragen.
Für mich kommt da noch ein zweiter Faktor dazu. Ausbildungen sind von der Idee her darauf ausgelegt, dass du noch bei deinen Eltern wohnst. Ich wohne nicht mehr bei meinen Eltern, weil meine Eltern in einem KUKAF in Rheinland-Pfalz wohnen. Da kann man keine Ausbildung machen mit Rechenzentrum und Internet. Ich hab eine eigene Wohnung in Berlin, ist nicht ganz billig und ich verdiene weit, weit, weit, weit unter Mindestlohn und verdiene schon mehr als meine Klassenkameraden. Also ich kann von dem, was ich verdiene, gerade so meine laufenden Kosten bezahlen und dann hab ich noch nichts gegessen.
Aber könntest du, also du bist jetzt bei einer Firma jetzt, dann könntest du sagen, so pass mal auf Leute, ich kann Zeug, ihr wisst auch, dass ich Zeug habe, ich hör jetzt mit der Ausbildung auf und ihr stellt mich einfach mal ordentlich an oder müsstest du dich dann sozusagen woanders hin bewerben?
Also ich hab mich schon mit meinem Ausbilder drüber unterhalten und der versteht mich und weiß auch und ist auch der Meinung, ja, ist nicht so optimal, aber Personalabteilungen sind so wie Personalabteilungen.
Natürlich.
Das heißt du müsstest, wenn du das nicht zu Ende machen willst, dann woanders hingehen und dich dann auch ohne Abschluss bewerben.
Ich glaube, das wäre für mich ein kleineres Problem. Einfach durch Kontakte und dadurch, dass ich mich schon seit ich denken kann mit der Informatik beschäftige. Für andere Leute ist es glaube ich eher ein Problem ohne diesen Schein was zu finden, aber das hängt ja von, denke ich auch davon ab, was du machen willst.
Das Problem glaube ich dabei ist, dass es eine Gefahr gibt, dass du irgendwann eben feststellst, du hast diese Ausbildung nicht abgeschlossen und wirst dann bei Firmen gar nicht mehr eingeladen. Und die Firma bei der du bist, weiß, dass du keinen anderen Job finden wirst und wird dir keine Gehaltserhöhungen geben und wird dich auch nicht befördern. Und es kann dir passieren, dass du immer so der Hilfsarbeiter und Zuarbeiter bleibst.
Das ist ganz witzig, weil die Sendung macht so einen dramatischen Verlauf. Informatikstuben, alle wollen das. Ja, so geil ist es eigentlich nicht. Aber eigentlich ist es keine schlechte Idee, dass wir das doch fertig machen. Also das heißt, man kann es nicht so ganz abschreiben. Wir werden in der nächsten halben Stunde mal gucken, genau wie das an der Uni unterteilt ist, was es da eigentlich so gibt. Wir haben ja schon kurz angesprochen, vorher gibt es aber noch ein kleines Stück Musik. Bamboo Boleen von Stein van Waageren. Interactive Dream Device ist das Album, von dem die Musik heute am Chaosradio 238 kommt. Und das Niederländer, der so ein bisschen Netzmusik macht oder Creative Commons Lizenz, kann man sich runterladen. Und das passt ganz gut zum heutigen Thema Informatikstudium, weil er sagt, das ist alles eher so Videospielgeräusch basierte Musik, die aber ruhiger ist, die man nebenher hören kann, wenn man zum Beispiel gerade fürs Studium. So und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio 238. Wir sprechen über Informatik, Studium und Ausbildung. Bei mir zu Gast sind Andreas Mutaks, Tobias und David. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück. Machen sie mal ein Geräusch, sie sind im Radio. Und Fernsehen. Und dann haben wir Publikum. Hallo Publikum. Wir haben jetzt schon eine Stunde darüber geredet, dass Informatikstudium eigentlich Unsinn ist, aber doch gar nicht so schlecht ist, fertig zu machen, wenn ich das mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen soll. Gibt es Fragen oder Anmerkungen momentan vom Publikum? Doch. Heben Sie die Hand. Wir haben hier Mikrofone, falls es bedarf besteht. Wir sind noch eine Stunde hier. Könnt ihr euch noch überlegen. Die nachdem wir jetzt erzählt haben, dass Informatikstudium vielleicht doch eine gute Idee sein kann, würde ich gerne also jetzt nicht im Detail, aber so ein bisschen wissen wollen, was da eigentlich passiert. Und ich kann mich noch grob erinnern, dass es in meiner Uni eine Unterteilung gab in technische, theoretische und praktische Informatik. Kommt das anwesenden bekannt vor?
Nicht so richtig. Theoretische gibt es an der TU auch als Begriff, aber praktische so als Begriff nicht.
Was ist in theoretischer Informatik?
Ja, so Leute, die sich mit Problemen beschäftigen, wie dem Halteproblem und Dinge, grundsätzlich unendlich viel Speicher haben. Und man eigentlich auch eher mit Formeln auf dem Blatt Papier arbeitet, statt mit Code, um es plakativ auszudrücken. Also eigentlich eher angewandte Mathematik. Weil es mit Computern zu tun hat, also mit abstrakten Berechenbarkeiten.
Kann ein Computerprogramm entscheiden, ob ein anderes Computerprogramm anhält oder endlos weiterläuft und in eine Endlostreife kommt?
Also es geht um Informatik. Es kommt darauf an, was da ist.
Ist das ein Angebot?
Nein.
Also meistens Kaffee. In meinem Informatikstudium gab es einen kleinen Kaffee, das war so 0, 2 Liter Becher und einen großen Kaffee, das war 0, 5 Liter. Also Filterkaffe, wo man merkt.
Ich habe jetzt immer nicht genau verstanden, was theoretische Informatik macht.
Informatik, also erstmal grundsätzlich. Handelt es sich von der Geschichte her um einen Zweig der Mathematik, der sich damit beschäftigt hatte, ob man Mathematik so weit formalisieren kann, dass man sie automatisieren kann. Die Frage ist, kann ich sozusagen eine Vorschrift für jemanden angeben, der dann entscheiden kann, anhand dieser Vorschrift, in dem man sie nacheinander ausführt, ob etwas wahr oder falsch ist? Das ging also los im 19. Jahrhundert mit Russell und dem Versuch sozusagen, die gesamte Mathematik zu akzomatisieren und zu formalisieren. Und da sind sie auch drauf gekommen, was kann man denn ausrechnen, was kann man nicht ausrechnen? Gibt es da Unterschiede? Was ist Berechenbarkeit? Und da sind sie also zu Modellen von Berechenbarkeit gekommen. Und eins davon ist die bekannte Thüring-Maschine, die nicht das eleganteste Modell der Berechenbarkeit ist, aber den schönen Vorteil hat, dass man im Prinzip sowas Ähnliches auch bauen kann. Das ist ein Automat und der hat ein Band und da schreibt er Dinge drauf und dann guckt er auf das Band drauf und dann entscheidet er anhand seines Zustands, dem was da steht, ob er jetzt das Band nach links schiebt oder nach rechts schiebt oder was drauf schreibt oder so. Und das ist schon relativ nah an etwas dran, was man bauen kann. Man kann sich also so ein Ding vorstellen, wo man so ein Band reinsteckt, also um Berechenbarkeit im abstrakten Gengster. Und daraus hat sich die Informatik entwickelt, auch weil sie festgestellt haben, irgendwann, naja, das kann man ja bauen. Und dann haben sie solche Maschinen gebaut und dann waren wir dann plötzlich in der praktischen Informatik.
Also, warte mal, also theoretische Informatik ist die theoretische Wissenschaft davon, was man unter Umständen praktisch bauen könnte, aber nicht tut, weil es nicht praktikabel ist.
Ja, was im abstrakten Sinne berechenbar ist. Also was kannst du ausrechnen? Das ist die Frage, die sich da stellen.
Aber das ist ja sozusagen, das ist im Prinzip was, das ist sehr universitär.
Das ist sehr universitär und abstrakt. Da schreibst du auch heutzutage mehr, aber früher schrieb man da keine Programme, sondern Papers. Und dann im nächsten Schritt guckt man sich die Komplexität von Algorithmen an. Also wie schnell bist du denn fertig damit? Ist es überhaupt lohnt sich, überhaupt anzufangen zu rechnen, weil du irgendwann ein Ergebnis kriegst?
Aber das hört sich schon wieder sehr praktisch an, dass sie sagen, ich schreibe eine Software, damit ich natürlich auch wissen, wie schnell die ist.
Das kann praktische Anwendungen haben. Also wir hatten in der Firma mal den Fall, dass wir überlegt haben, ob wir eine Software jetzt optimieren. Das heißt, ob wir einen Programmierer eine Woche hinsetzen, um das Programm schneller zu machen, oder ob wir einfach das Programm laufen lassen, weil wir es eh nur zweimal laufen lassen. Und dann musste man halt ausrechnen, wie viel schneller kann man das Programm theoretisch kriegen, rentiert sich der Arbeitsaufwand von einer Woche oder lassen es einfach laufen, weil so oft wird es eh nicht laufen und wir müssen das noch einmal machen zum Importieren. Da ging es glaube ich darum, die Wikipedia zu importieren oder sowas.
Tatsächlich hat die theoretische Informatik auch praktische Relevanz, sonst würde man das ja nicht machen.
Du möchtest zum Beispiel, dass jemand beweist, dass der Code, der im Flugzeug läuft, nicht einfach so anhält.
Und das geht dann auch, ja?
Das ist verschieden gut. Die Art und Weise, wie Code für Flugzeuge geschrieben werden, ist ganz schön mühselig. Also die schreiben so was wie 100 Zeilen C-Code pro Monat pro Programmierer, weil der Aufwand so groß ist.
Das immer noch zu kontrollieren, dass das noch funktioniert?
Genau, genau. Das hat allerdings mittelmäßig, also zunehmend mehr mit theoretischer Informatik zu tun. Früher war das einfach alles manuelle Prüfungen und Dokumentation. Man hat also irgendwie 20 Zeilen Code geschrieben und dafür erst mal 100 Seiten Text mit Requirement, Analyse, Testing, Interaktion mit anderen Systemen, Impact-Analyse, Risiko-Analyse und so einen ganzen Quatsch gemacht. Und heutzutage kann man dann teilweise schon mal eine Software drüber laufen lassen, die sich die Software anguckt und sagt, die hat Eigenschaft XY.
Aber dann muss die Software, die da drüber läuft, natürlich auch bewiesen sein.
Da können wir mal eine eigene Sendung drüber machen.
Okay, gut. Vertiefen wir das nicht, aber halten wir fest, theoretische Informatik ist die arcane Magie. Kann man auch ohne theoretische Informatik Informatik studieren?
Ja, man kann dem größten Teil entgehen.
Also das geht schon. Es gibt halt Grundlagenvorlesungen, da muss man durch. Da lernt man auch Automatentheorie zum Beispiel. Das ist auch durchaus alles hilfreich, weil so eine Automat... Eine Automat braucht man, wenn man Netzwerkprotokoll implementieren möchte, so was wie TCP oder so. Da gibt es halt Zustände. Da ist so ein Verständnis für Automatentheorie schon sehr hilfreich, wenn man sowas mal selber machen möchte.
Aber Grundlagen und dann ist auch gut. Das geht schon.
Also ich hab zum Beispiel keinen einzigen Schein in theoretischer Informatik.
Du bist ja auch ganz komisch.
Also lustig finde ich... Also insbesondere das mit den TCP-Paketen und den Sprachen, das ist eine Geschichte, wo die theoretische Informatik und die praktische Informatik... Ich erklär's gleich, ich hol gleich mal aus. Aber es ist da, wo die Welten miteinander kollidieren, wo die Realität einfach nicht so ist, wie du das im Studium lernst. Also Sprachen, da gab es mal diesen Chomsky, den man hauptsächlich als Sprachwissenschaftler kennt. Mittlerweile gibt er auch öfter mal im Fernsehen seine Meinung zum politischen Weltgeschehen ab. Aber der hat zur Informatik auch was beigetragen, nämlich an der Systematisierung von Sprachen, von Computersprachen, sowas wie HTML oder Programmiersprachen. Und der hat da Hierarchien für aufgebaut. Und zu den Hierarchien der Sprachen gehören verschiedene Algorithmen, mit denen man diese Sprachen dann parsen kann, also sich auseinandernehmen, sich angucken kann und so. Und da gibt es also so grobe Unterscheidungen wie reguläre Ausdrücke, Regular Expressions, hat der ein oder andere schon mal gesehen, die man mit einem solchen Automaten lösen kann. Und dann gibt es Sachen, die zum Beispiel Klammern haben, wo für jede geöffnete Klammer auch hinten wieder eine Klammer zugemacht werden muss. Und da muss man sich irgendwo merken, wie viele Klammern aufgemacht werden, damit die auch alle wieder zugemacht werden können. Und das muss man irgendwo auf einen Stack tun. So einen Stapel haben, wo man sich das merkt und ablegt. So als grobe Hierarchie. Da denkst du irgendwie, toll, großartig, ich hab die Welt verstanden. Kommst du in den Praxis und stellst dann erstmal fest, dass die Perl-Regular-Expressions gar keine regulären Ausdrücke sind, sondern viel mächtiger und auch gar nicht.
Also ich habe verstanden, ich hab zwischendurch was verstanden, nämlich wenn man Programme schreibt, macht man viele Klammern, dann muss man darauf achten, dass man in den Klammern, die man aufgemacht hat, auch irgendwann wieder zu macht. Den Rest habe ich nicht verstanden.
Das sozusagen, das mit dem Klammern zählt, ist schon eine kompliziertere Sprache als, was ist eine Regular-Expression? Das ist sowas wie irgendwie, also alle Elemente meiner Sprache sind 3 As, gefolgt von 0 oder beliebig vielen Bs. Also A, A, A, B oder A, A, A, B, B sind alles Worte aus meiner Sprache. Definier ich so. Da musst du aber nicht zählen. Da kannst du irgendwie sagen, naja, wenn ich ein B gesehen habe, dann bin ich im Zustand, ich habe ein B gesehen. Wenn ich noch ein B sehe, bin ich wieder im Zustand, ich habe ein B gesehen. Da muss man sich nichts merken. Außer irgendwie, man ist gerade im Zustand, man hat ein B gesehen und nicht irgendwie mitzählen. Theoretische Informatik erzählt dir, für welche Sprachen du mitzählen musst und für welche nicht mitzählen musst. Und das macht dann was? Davon hängt ab, was du für einen Algorithmus brauchst, um die Sprache zu verstehen. Also ob du das einfach machen kannst oder ob das schwierig ist. Und am Ende des Tages hat das aber alles nichts mit der wirklichen Welt zu tun, weil in der Praxis wird alles komplett anders gemacht.
Ja, aber in der Praxis gibt es dann immer wieder Leute, die wollen dann HTML mit Regular Expressions wie SED, AWK oder so parsen und wundern sich, warum das dann nicht funktioniert.
Leute, was?
HTML ist halt sowas, da muss man sich Dinge merken. Und bei Regular Expressions geht das nicht so einfach. Also eigentlich gar nicht. Und deswegen, wenn man Komsky zugehört hat, weiß man, dass man mit einer regulären AWK niemand mit HTML parsen kann.
Okay, lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Wenn ich verstehen will, was ihr gerade geredet habt in den letzten 10 Minuten, muss ich dann theoretisch Informatik studiert haben?
Oder diesen Stackoverflow-Artikel dazu lesen. Im Prinzip ist das ein typischer Bestandteil Grundkurs theoretischer Informatik und auch einer, an dem man fast nicht vorbeikommt. Das ist so klassische Informatik 50er Jahre.
Ich entschuldige mich an dieser Stelle bei den Hörern und Hörerinnen, weil ich sozusagen nicht schaffe, das so aufzuklären, dass das, glaube ich, wirklich jeder versteht. Das wird so schwierig. Machen wir deswegen schnell weiter. Es gibt also theoretische Informatik. Bei mir war es praktische, hieß das. Da ging es um Datenbanken, wie man die macht, oder Compilerbau. Gibt es sowas als eigenes Kapitel?
Wir hatten damals nur diesen Compilerbau.
Ich glaube, es gab auch einzelne. Nicht als einzelner Paket praktischer Informatik. Es gab Datenbanksysteme, es gab Betriebssystempraktikungen, es gab ein Ding, wo man ein bestimmtes Netzwerk programmiert hat. Der ganze Netzwerk kam, das gab es aber als einzelner Block, aber nicht zusammengefasst unter dem Begriff.
Und was noch? Technische Informatik?
Technische Informatik ist ein eigener Studiengang bei uns, der die Elektrotechnik und die Informatik versucht, unter einen Hut zu bringen. Das heißt, man lernt aus beiden das Schlimmste, ich meine aus beiden das Beste. Was es seit ein paar Jahren erst gibt, ist an der TU zum Beispiel die Wirtschaftsinformatik, weil die TU gesagt hat, wir hätten gerne eine Wirtschaftsinformatik, die mehr technischen Fokus hat. An anderen Unis ist es so, dass man da mehr einen Wirtschaftsfokus hat und nebenbei noch ein bisschen Informatik lernt. Es gibt Bioinformatik, aber das sind alles einzelne Studiengänge.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie genau sind denn diese verheirateten Fachgänge zu verstehen? Ist es einfach, dass ich halbe halbe studiere?
Das kommt immer sehr drauf an.
Ich hasse diese juristischen Antworten, dass die Rechtsanwälte sagen, es kommt drauf an.
Es hat schon viele gemeinsame Grundlagen. Die ganze Grundlage der Programmierung und Mathematik und Informatik, das hörst du halt immer. Und in der Bioinformatik, dann hörst du auch ein bisschen Biologie mit. Und vieles ist dann halt eine Vorlesung oder irgendwie zwei, drei Vorlesungen über die Semester verteilt. Und dann war es das. Und die hören dann auch Leute aus verschiedenen Fachbereichen. Also so was wie Compilerbau war zum Beispiel zwei, drei Vorlesungen. Oder 3D-Grafik kann das sein, dass du noch mal zwei, drei Vorlesungen hast. Dann gibt es dann noch die Leute, die Spiele Design studieren, die machen dann auch noch die 3D-Grafik und kriegen nebenbei noch einen Kurs in, wie das eigentlich mit dieser Kunst funktioniert und Gestaltung und so und wie man Geschichte erzählt. Oder wie gesagt in der Bioinformatik, wie das mit der Zelle ist und der DNA und wie die Proteine gefaltet werden. Da hat man dann schon sozusagen Spezialisierung, wo man eine ganze Menge Informatik lernt, aber dann jeweils auch noch einen anderen Bereich dazu.
Ich denke, wir sollten erst mal kurz zerlegen, wie so ein Studium eigentlich generell aussieht. Und das ist, dass man eigentlich erst mal diesen Block hat, drei bis vier Jahre, je nachdem, wo man macht. Das ist ein Bachelor, was früher so irgendwie das Grundstudium war. Dann hat man noch mal so eine, na, ein bis zwei Jahre, je nachdem, wann und wo man irgendwie seinen Master macht dahinter. Master. Und dann hast du eben auch noch erwähnt, dann gibt es halt noch den PhD, also die Promotion dahinter. Und das können dann noch mal so vier, fünf, sechs Jahre, also fast genauso lang, wenn nicht sogar länger, als der ganze Block davor sein, bis man dann halt wirklich so ein Informatikstudium wirklich bis zum ultimativen Endboss durchgespielt hat.
Aber macht man Doktor auch, wenn man nicht im Wissenschaftsbetrieb bleiben will?
Also ich versuch das gerade zum Beispiel. Ich arbeite momentan an der Uni, aber ich werde, wenn ich dann irgendwann mal erfolgreich promoviert habe, nicht an der Uni bleiben. Weil dann bin ich auch zu alt.
Aber zurück zum ersten Schritt. Also es gibt das Bachelorstudium slash Grundstudium. Ist das dann für alle gleich? Also ist das quasi wie Schule nur an der Uni? Nee, auch schon nicht.
Also die Technikinformatiker an der TU zum Beispiel haben Vorlesungen aus der Informatik und aus der Elektrotechnik. Die ITM, IT im Maschinenbau oder sowas. Die haben komplett eigene Vorlesungen. Das ist dann zwar auch was mit starkem Informatikfokus, aber die haben eigentlich keine... Also die haben für sich alleine.
Ich hab Frage falsch gestellt. Ich meinte nicht sozusagen, ob die verschiedenen Studiengänge, die Informatik im Namen tragen, unterschiedlich sind, sondern wenn ich mich einschreibe für ein bestimmtes Studium und dann sozusagen das bis zum Bachelor bringe, machen dann alle Kommilitonen, die sich zum selben Zeitpunkt eingeschrieben haben, dasselbe wie ich? Oder finden da auch schon Spezialisierungen statt?
So 80 Prozent, es gibt aber Spezialisierungen. Also wir haben Studiengebiete, heißt das, glaube ich, an der TU, wo es zum Beispiel mehr Richtung Netzwerk gehen kann oder mehr Richtung Programmierung.
Aber 20 Prozent, das ist dann sozusagen so, dass da ein Häubchen oben drauf, eigentlich machen alle dasselbe?
Also vor allem der Punkt danach machen sie nicht alle dasselbe. Ja, also wenn die erstmal ihren Bachelor haben, dann können...
Genau, deswegen die Frage war erstmal bis zum Bachelor?
Wenn man in einem Studium gegangen ist, ist das relativ homogen.
Und ist es so, dass man mit dem Bachelor sozusagen auch schon aufhören kann? Oder ist der Master quasi... Also die Politik sagt ja.
Die Politik sagt ja, und das passt, glaube ich, auch.
Nee, ich möchte aber von euch... Also auch wenn es albern, klingt die Praxis besser.
In der Praxis wird man glaube ich nicht so richtig glücklich.
In der Praxis heißt es immer Hochschulabschluss erwünscht oder gleichartige Qualifikation der Berufserfahrung.
Aber ist Bachelor dann schon quasi...
Es kommt drauf an, wo im öffentlichen Dienst nicht, ja. Aber wenn du dich bei einer Firma bewirbst, ist es echt so, dass die... ob du studiert hast und was du studiert hast, schon so ein bisschen nachrangig ist. Sondern irgendwie, wenn du zeigen kannst, naja, ich hab halt hier fünf Jahre bei der Firma XY Projekt Z geleitet, was am besten auch noch bekannt ist, und kann das und das und das und das, dann wirst du im Interview getestet, ob du das und das und das wirklich kannst und dann wirst du angestellt.
Okay, also sagen, es ist relativ wahrscheinlich, wenn ich an der Uni bin und nicht mein Studium sowieso irgendwie in den Wind schießen will, dass ich dann auch noch Master hinterher mache. Wie sieht der aus? Der ist dann spezialisierter? Oder ist das auch so ganz klar reglementiert, was da passiert? Sollte der Schwierigkeitsgrad nicht ansteigen?
Der Bachelor vermittelt die ganzen Grundlagen. Das heißt, du musst dich durch diesen ganzen Kram durchquälen, der dich eigentlich gar nicht so richtig interessiert. Und auch durch diese Mathe-Vorlesung. Und meine Erfahrung, ich hab Diplom studiert, war, dass dann im Hauptstudium plötzlich alles total einfach wurde. Weil ich konnte mich plötzlich auf die Sachen konzentrieren, die mich wirklich interessiert haben, die ich spannend fand. Und das fällt einem dann natürlich unendlich viel leichter, wenn man auch viel leichter oder viel lieber sich mit den Sachen beschäftigt.
Außerdem sind die Grundstudiumsveranstaltungen, also bei uns damals, als es noch Grundstudium hieß, die waren immer Montag morgens um 8. Und die Hauptstudiumsveranstaltung, also was heute Master ist, das ist dann immer so gegen Nachmittag gewesen.
Das kommt auch dazu, ja.
Sehr, sehr gut. So, und dann bin ich aber fertig mit dem Hochschulstudium, wenn ich will. Kann aber auch noch promovieren. Jetzt finde ich das ganz lustig, weil mir gerade auffällt, ich kenne mittlerweile genug Leute, die das versucht haben und auch fertig gemacht haben, deswegen weiß ich, wie das geht. Aber könntest du mal für Menschen, die vielleicht gerade am Anfang stehen und sich überlegen, wäre das was für mich, was genau ist das eigentlich, dieses Promovieren? Wie mache ich das? Okay, wenn ihr diese Blicke jetzt gesehen hättet, dann wüsstet ihr, dass die eigentliche Antwort auf die Frage ist, man macht es nicht.
Vier Jahre Schmerz. Was ist einfach zu beantworten? Ein Armutsrisiko. Also das ist unheimlich zeitraubend, weil man tatsächlich selbstständig wissenschaftlich arbeitet und hinterher ein Werk rausbringen muss, was sozusagen etwas Neues schafft. Die Theorie ist, wenn du deine Bachelorarbeit schreibst, dann musst du im Wesentlichen beweisen, dass du gut darin bist, Bücher zu lesen, das Gelesene wiederzugeben. Bei einer Masterarbeit ist es schon so ein bisschen, naja, mal auch was Eigenes bauen, aber jetzt schon unter Anleitung auf den existieren Gebieten. So ein PhD, so ein Doktorabschluss, da ist die Anforderung, dass du etwas Neues selbst tätig schaffst. Und das ist in der Regel sehr umfangreich. Dich leitet auch keiner an. Du hast vielleicht einen Doktorvater, mit dem du dich mal austauschen kannst.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, mal ganz praktisch zu sagen, also eine Masterarbeit ist, glaube ich, um die 80 Seiten. Was ist deine Doktorarbeit in der Vergiltnis und wie lange habe ich dafür Zeit und was mache ich währenddessen?
Es gibt jetzt nur von fünf Seiten, aber die sind sehr selten.
In der Regel doppelt so lange wie so eine Masterarbeit. Aber auch schon mit einem höheren Anspruch. Das ist, glaube ich, das Problem dabei. Im Anspruch selber scheitern auch viele Leute. Du brauchst erstens die Disziplin, kontinuierlich daran zu arbeiten, ohne dass jemand irgendwie alle drei Tage dasteht und fragt, hast du schon wieder eine Seite geschrieben. Die gesamte Literaturrecherche zu machen, das so zu dokumentieren, dass du es hinterher wieder findest. Dann stellst du mittendrin fest, dass die Theorie, von der du ausgegangen bist, auf die du deine Arbeit aufbaust, eigentlich völliger Blödsinn ist. Dann kommt noch mal was Neues raus. Oder, keine Ahnung, dir wird langweilig, weil du schon Ewigkeiten in diesem Thema kaust. Das sind so die typischen Probleme, die an dir treffen.
Plus noch dieser ganze Verwaltungskram. Wenn du an einer großen Universität bist, mit starken Sparauflagen, wie der TU Berlin, dann hast du plötzlich 800, 900 Studenten, die du betreuen musst mit drei Leuten. Du musst halt noch nebenbei diese ganze Lehre organisieren und hast noch eine ganze Reihe anderer Aufgaben, parallel zu deiner eigentlichen Promotion.
Ich schreibe eine Doktorarbeit gleichbedeutend mit. Ich bin an einer Uni angestellt und auch für die Lehre zuständig.
Nicht unbedingt, aber das ist sehr üblich. Du musst ja von irgendwas leben in der Zeit. Deswegen sage ich, es handelt sich um ein Armutsrisiko. Der übliche Weg ist, dass du an einer Uni als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter angestellt bist. Das ist ganz unglaublich schlecht bezahlt, wie überhaupt alle akademischen Jobs in Deutschland unglaublich schlicht bezahlt sind.
Da würde ich jetzt mal, vor allem beim Berliner IT-Stellenmarkt, ganz stark widersprechen.
An einer Uni stellen?
Ich muss feststellen, dass die vier Jahre, die ich jetzt mit promovieren verbracht habe, ich durchgehend mehr Geld als meine Partnerin auch in der IT-Führungsposition auch einen Master verdient habe. Aber nicht an einer Uni? Ich war an der TU Berlin.
Ach so, was ist denn TU Berlin?
TVL 13.
Was heißt das?
Das heißt, dass ich aktuell TVL 13 Stufe 3, also mit jetzt vier Jahren an der Uni, mit gut 50.000 Brutteln nach Hause gehe.
Als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter? Wie viele Leute musstest du in den Rücken stechen, um an diese Stelle zu kommen?
Keinen. Der Vorteil des Informatikers ist, dass er in der Regel auch volle Stellen kriegt an der Uni, wenn er möchte. Archäologen bekommen eine 16. Stelle, damit sie versichert sind, wenn sie im Labor arbeiten.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Informatikstunden bist du ja gerade sehr beliebt. Ist es trotzdem so, dass an der Uni Fachkräftemangel was die Mitarbeiter angeht, ist?
Es gibt halt keine Stellen, weil gespart werden muss. Aber wenn du gut bist und einen Doktorvater, eine Doktermutter findest, die meint, dass du promotionswürdig bist und dich einstellt, dann hast du einen sicheren Job die nächsten Jahre.
Okay, aber es ist schon so, dass auch das, also auf eine Stelle wollen dann 100 Leute und ihr beiden selbst sein, die die Glück gehabt haben.
Den Eindruck hab ich jetzt eher nicht so, nee. Weil du verdienst halt nicht so viel wie in einer freien Wirtschaft, wenn du halbwegs geschickt dich anstellst.
Moment, ich nehme einen Widerspruch.
Und halt bereit bist auch nicht in Berlin zu bleiben zum Beispiel.
Wie lange dauert so eine Doktorarbeit?
Offiziell drei Jahre.
Wie lange schreibt ihr beiden schon?
Vier, knapp.
Ich hab das Ding nach drei Jahren und neun Monaten Roundabout abgegeben.
Okay, das heißt du bist jetzt Doktor?
Nee, noch nicht ganz. Ich muss noch den Endboss der Berliner Verwaltung besiegen.
Was heißt das? Ist das nur eine Formsache? Also den grünen Passierschein A2?
Erstens sind die Formulare bei uns an der Uni blau und gelb, um Scheine zu kriegen. Und die müssen mit Durchschlag gemacht werden. Und es ist in der Tat ein PDF-Format, das muss noch veröffentlicht werden. Da müssen noch so ein paar grüne Passierscheine ausgestellt werden.
Aber du musst jetzt nicht noch irgendwie einen Vortrag halten?
Das hat er schon gemacht. Das hab ich inzwischen hinter mir. Aber es ist jetzt noch wirklich der Verwaltungsboss.
Was passiert als nächstes? Also wenn der gelegt ist?
Wenn der gelegt ist, ganz ehrlich, ich fliege aus diesem Land und aus diesem Unisystem. Weil? Weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass universitäre Lehre, so wie ich sie bisher, zumindest im Rahmen meiner Promotion erleben durfte, nicht unbedingt das System ist, in dem ich forschen und lernen möchte.
Aber du möchtest forschen und lernen, gehst deswegen an ein anderes Land, an ein anderes Unisystem? Davon fragen, wohin?
Ich geh in die Niederlande.
Weil die da was anders machen?
Weil sie da mehr grundständiges Funding für die Lehre bieten und weil sie da eine Perspektive auf Lehre haben, wo sie einfach Lehre machen wollen und Menschen, unabhängig davon, wo sie gerade sind, versuchen, mit Wissen auszustatten, Wissen so zu dokumentieren, dass Leute das nutzen können, ob sie jetzt nur mal an der Uni sind oder nicht.
Das heißt, in Deutschland wird Lehre ab und zu empfunden, als, oh Gott, wir müssen das auch noch machen. Und da ist das wirklich Lebenszweck.
Das ist halt unterfinanziert. Auch wenn du gute Lehre machen möchtest, musst du halt woanders Abstriche machen. Also entweder ich mache gute Lehre, oder ich schreibe ein Paper, damit ich irgendwann mal eine Promotion schreiben kann.
Würdet ihr denn auch sagen, vielleicht im Ausland studieren, ist eine gute Idee?
Ja, definitiv.
Es gibt schon sehr namhafte Unis, die sich nicht in Deutschland befinden.
Wohin sollte man gehen?
Also University of Michigan ist sehr gut. Wenn man MMIT oder einen Stanfordenplatz kriegt, das sind gute Unis. Inria in Frankreich, Cambridge, alles namhafte Orte.
Das sind die klassischen großen Namen, die man im Kontext haben kann.
Ich möchte in dem Kontext meine Alma mater vorne heben. Es gibt die Universität von Amsterdam. Die hatten ein Studienprogramm, das heißt Network Engineering. Es ist massiv angewandt. Gleichzeitig aber trotzdem in universitärer Maße, mit dem man am Ende auch promovieren gehen kann. Nein, Tannenbaum ist an der VU, einer Freien Universität. In der Tat hatten wir noch einen Kurs an der Freien Universität, gehen aber auch bei einem Kollegen von Tannenbaum.
Jetzt musst du doch kurz erklären, wer Tannenbaum ist.
Tannenbaum ist einer der großen Menschen von Betriebssystembau.
Das ist der, der als dieser Linus damals mit dem Linux angefangen hat, ihm erzählt hat, mit dem Systemdesign hätte ich dich bei mir durchfallen lassen.
Okay, gut, also die großen Namen. In die Niederlande könnte man gehen. Noch was?
KU Leuven ist auch eine sehr gute Uni, auch in den Niederlanden.
Okay, in den Niederlanden haben wir noch was? Also noch ein Land sozusagen?
Jedes, wo man sich wohlfühlt.
Na ja, außer Deutschland, weil da ist ja... Oder ist das universitäre System so schlimm, dass man sagt, geht überall hin, nur nicht in Deutschland?
Also geht auf jeden Fall nicht an eine große Uni, würde ich sagen. Weil an einer großen Uni bist du verloren. Da kümmert sich niemand um dich, wenn es dir schlecht geht oder wenn du nicht mitkommst.
Seht ihr die Behörerinnen und Hörer? Vor zwei Stunden ungefähr habe ich gefragt, an welche Uni man gehen soll. Ich sage, es ist egal, in Deutschland kann man überall hingehen. Mittlerweile betreiben wir Landflucht und sagen, wenn ihr schon in Deutschland bleibt, dann lieber nicht an eine große Uni.
Die Frage am Anfang war aber, welche Uni in Deutschland?
Naja, aber selbst da hieß es sozusagen, es ist egal.
Dann sind die alle gar schlimm.
Na gut, wir werden sozusagen in der letzten halben Stunde noch mal genauer versuchen zu erklären, welche Ausbildungsform vielleicht die beste ist. Vorher gibt es noch ein ganz, ganz kleines Stück Musik.
Providers kritisieren geplante Breitbandmessung. Klaus Landefeld vom Eco-Verband der Internetwirtschaft kritisierte bei Heise Online die von der Bundesnetzagentur angestrebte neue Breitbandmessung per Applikation. Bei der bisherigen browserbasierten Breitbandmessung sei es nicht auf die Qualität eines einzelnen Anschlusses angekommen. Künftig sollten die Ergebnisse aber im Zweifelsfall vor Gericht als Beweis gelten. Daraus ergäben sich sehr hohe Anforderungen an das Analyseinstrument. Diese können nur erfüllt werden, wenn das entsprechende Werkzeug auf dem Breitbandrouter installiert würde. Links unten unbewaffnet. Beim Vorgehen gegen vermeintliche Betreiberinnen und Betreiber von Indymedia links unten wurden keine gefährlichen Gegenstände bei den Verdächtigen gefunden. Dies teilte das Bundesinnenministerium auf Nachfrage von netzpolitik.org mit. Der Bundesinnenminister Thomas de Maizière hatte auf einer Pressekonferenz am Morgen der Durchsuchung behauptet, bei den Betroffenen seien Waffen beschlagnahmt worden. ZITES Eröffnung abgesagt. ZITES hatte schon im Mai die Arbeit aufgenommen. Gestern sollte die zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich offiziell eröffnet werden. Die Feier wurde aber kurzfristig abgesagt. Als Grund wurde angegeben, dass Innenminister de Maizière aus Termingründen nicht kommen konnte. Es wird spekuliert, dass der eigentliche Grund der Absage die Tatsache ist, dass von den für dieses Jahr vorgesehenen 120 Planstellen bislang gerade einmal 17 besetzt werden konnten.
Wisst ihr woran das liegt? Die sind alle bei der Cyberfeuerwehr. So, das waren die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Mo, präsentiert von Helena. Vorher gab es noch die Musik von Stein van Waageren. Circe, hieß der Track, die auf dem Sofa wurde schon gebotert. Die Songs würden sich alle gleich anhören. Es ist halt ein Ambient-Album. Es ist halt so ruhig und entspannt. Ich lege meine Hand dafür ins Feuer, dass es drei unterschiedliche Tracks waren. Links zu allem auf chaosradio.ccc.de am Montag.
In der Pause gab es Kritik.
Woran?
Ich soll nicht sagen, dass jede große Uni scheiße ist.
Ach so, die Kamera ist ja nicht sehr doof. Können wir kurz die Kamera zuhalten? Wir haben viele Leute auf dem Sofa. Jetzt bitte mal die Hand heben. Wer diese Kritik sozusagen, also wer nicht daran glaubt, dass alle großen Unis doof sind? Bitte mal Hand heben. Also alle großen Unis sind doof, stimmt das? Ja, dann die Hand heben.
Du hast die Frage umgedreht.
Ja, ich hab die Frage umgedreht, aber anscheinend hat sie vorher. Gut, danke, vielen Dank. Also ich sag jetzt mal so, also Freunde haben mir erzählt, also alle großen Unis sind doof. Warum kritisiert man das? Weil man selber an einer großen Uni so ein Stockholm-Syndrom hat, oder?
Also ich kenne halt die Nachteile einer großen Uni und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es an einer kleinen Uni anders ist. Hab aber selber eine kleine Uni nie erlebt, persönlich.
Aber da haben wir doch hier jemanden, der eine kleine Uni erlebt hat.
Ja, und auch eine kleine Uni kann sich diese großen Probleme ziehen. Also das ist so ein ganz klassisches Problem, was Studieren extrem scheiße macht. Zentralisiertes Prüfungsamt. Einfach dieses, wir haben jetzt unsere 26.000 Studierenden und wir haben jetzt ein Prüfungsamt. Da sitzen dann 100 Sachbearbeitende drin. Also zwischen Anspruch und Realität. Und für die ist halt jede studierende Person gleich. Ob das jetzt irgendwie Philosophie, Informatik, das ist halt so ein Sachvorgang, der muss bearbeitet werden. Und es wird extrem viel angenehmer, wenn man ein studienfachbezogenes Prüfungsamt hat, wo Menschen sitzen, für die man wirklich ein Mensch ist und die sich mit Problemen von einzelnen Menschen auseinandersetzen können. Wenn dann mal irgendwie ein Schein zu spät kommt, um gerade diese 50 ECTS, die man nach den ersten ein, zwei Semestern haben muss, zu kriegen. Wenn sie sich halt verspätet unter wirklich Menschen sitzen und sagen so, okay, ja, ich hau jetzt unserem Institutsleiter nochmal auf die Finger, dass der Schein jetzt auch mal wirklich, wirklich, wirklich kommen muss. So, das ist was vollkommen anderes, als wenn da jemand sitzt so, ja, das haben mir heute schon 20 Leute erzählt, ist mir egal. Man hat bei so einer kleinen Uni mehr Chancen, sondern nicht zentralisiertes Prüfungsamt zu haben.
Und du hast vielleicht auch nicht 23 verschiedene Studienprogramme, wie Leute sich für irgendeine Vorlesung registrieren.
Ist es auch von Vorteil, in einer kleinen Stadt zu studieren, weil da nicht so viele Studenten hinkommen, also quasi die Uni auch nicht dann so aus allen Nähten platzt?
Actually, kleine Städte neigen dazu, wirklich sehr Studierenden dominiert zu sein. Vor allem so diese kleinen Unis, die ich kenne, so Münster aus Naabrück, die Städte haben so einen richtig dicken Studierendenstempel. Da merkt man mehr, dass da Studierende sind als hier in Berlin.
Das kann ja sein, aber das kann ja trotzdem bedeuten, dass nicht die Klassenräuber, ich bin nicht, aber die Jahrgänge sozusagen total überfüllt sind.
Ich würde mir schon denken, dass die vielleicht kleiner sind, weil die Kapazitäten auch gar nicht so groß sind. Wenn ich mir angucke, wir an der TU haben eine Erstsemester-Vorlesung, da registrieren sich halt 950 Studierende. Und dann sitzen da halt 900 Leute, das wird dann sehr schnell weniger. Aber am Ende vom Semester sind immer noch 720 davon übrig. Und du sitzt halt mit 720 Leuten im Hörsaal.
Die haben wie viele Betreuer?
Also theoretisch sollten 20 Personen im Turm sitzen, praktisch sind es 40. Und es gibt halt vier WM, die das dann irgendwie versuchen müssen zu betreuen. Also sagen wir mal so, fünf Leute machen es, zwei werden bezahlt. Weil du hast halt nur für zwei Leute die Stellen, die das machen. Und wenn du ein sehr engagiertes Fachgebiet bist, dann machen halt alle damit. Und wenn du ein Fachgebiet hast, das sowieso wenig Ressourcen hat, dann sind halt da zwei Leute und dann gibt es halt Vorlesungen aus der Konserve und es wird irgendwie mit minimal Effort dafür gesorgt, dass das halbwegs geht. Aber da ist halt keine persönliche Betreuung drin.
Um Gottes Willen. So ich würde jetzt mal hier in das Publikum gucken wollen. Liebes Publikum, wer von euch hat Informatik studiert oder hat vor Informatik zu studieren? Bitte mal die Hand heben. Das sind bitte oben lassen. Sehr schön. Wer wird es nochmal genau so entscheiden? Das sieht nicht so gut aus für das Informatikstudium.
Ganz kurz, aus Gründen, weil das Studium von der Organisation her oder wie es war blöd war, weil die Inhalte doof waren.
Das ist nichts, was man durch Handzeichen beantworten kann. Zum Abschluss der Sendung ist es gefuchtet.
Können wir da nicht nochmal einen positiven Aspekt reinbringen?
Ja, bitte.
Man muss auch sagen, ein Studienabschluss an einer großen Universität ist ein Signal für einen potenziellen Arbeitgeber, dass man in der Lage ist, mit einer wirren, komplexen, starren Bürokratie umzugehen.
Aber dazu müsste der Arbeitgeber dieses Chaosradio gehört haben. Moment, also tatsächlich ist diese Sendung eine Sendung voller Widerspruch. Ich höre erst irgendwie, es ist egal, in welche Uni man geht. Also Abschluss machen ist sowieso völlig überbewertet. Die Arbeitgeber wollen sowieso nicht irgendwie sehen, welchen Schein du hast, sondern die wollen wissen, wo dein GitHub-Account ist. Und jetzt höre ich dann wieder so, naja, es gibt schon gute Unis. Und der Arbeitgeber ist ja auch, wenn man da durchkommt an die große Stadt, dann weiß der Arbeitgeber auch, dass man sich durchbeißen kann.
Das ist immer die Frage, was willst du signalisieren, wo willst du hin im Leben? Willst du fröhlich vor dich hin einen Code schreiben? Oder hast du Aspiration, irgendwann mal als CTO im Vorstand zu sitzen?
Ähm, so, wir bauen das jetzt eine Reihe nach nochmal. Ich will was mit Computern machen. Soll ich Informatik studieren? Ja oder nein? Und wenn ja, warum nicht? Wir haben am Anfang der Sendung gefragt, warum habt ihr Informatik studiert? Die Antwort war in Abweichung immer so, ich wollte was mit Computern machen.
Um was mit Computern zu machen, brauchst du kein Studium. Aber wenn du was mit Computern machst, dann ermöglicht dir ein Studium Dinge, die ohne nicht gehen. Du kannst irgendwie problemlos glücklich werden mit Programmieren. Du kannst den ganzen Tag an tollen Projekten arbeiten und in Ruby irgendwelche Backends für Apps programmieren und die Apps selber ohne irgendwas damit zu tun zu haben, was in der Informatik schon vermittelt wird. Aber es gibt Spezialisierungen, die von der Informatik hilft. Wenn du irgendwie im Compilerbau landen willst oder in 3D-Grafik, weil dir einfach abgefahrener Frickelkram Spaß macht, den man sonst nirgendwo lernt. Oder wenn du halt Aspirationen hast, in der Firma auch mal ein bisschen aufzusteigen, ins Management zu gehen, vielleicht auch ins Upper Management. Da ist das quasi so ein Schein, wo dir bescheinigt wird, du bist in der Lage, unter widrigen Bedingungen Dinge zu erreichen. Da geht es nicht um die Inhalte, da geht es um, du hast dich da durchgekämpft.
Das ist aber nicht die Eintrittskarte, sondern das ist nur die Zugangsberechtigung für die Lotterie.
Genau.
So ein Studium kann natürlich auch schaden.
Leute!
Das muss gesagt werden. Es kann halt passieren, dass du überqualifiziert bist. Wenn du dann fröhlich vor dich hin promoviert hast, wirst du halt nicht mehr so eine normal, nicht so super bezahlte Coda-Stelle kriegen. Weil du halt möglicherweise nicht mehr als einfacher Programmierer angestellt wirst. Weil die Firma der Meinung ist, der es promoviert, den können wir nicht so bezahlen oder so. Das kann halt passieren, dass du plötzlich auch in die Schiene Management gedrückt wirst, weil du bist doch promoviert, du kannst das doch, obwohl du da gar nicht hin möchtest.
David, würdest du jetzt noch mal studieren wollen?
Ich hab damals mein Abitur abgebrochen, weil ich eh nicht studieren wollte.
Aber mit einer Ausbildung kann man studieren. Mit Ausbildung und Berufserfahrung kann man möglicherweise die Hochschulzugangsberechtigung nachweisen. Da gibt es irgendwelche wirren Wege.
Ich glaube, da muss man noch mal ein Jahr irgendwie einen anderen Bildungsweg ranhängen oder so. Es ist nicht so einfach.
Das ist relativ einfach. Die Fachhochschulzugangsberechtigung, die kriegst du auf jeden Fall mit so einem Physi zusammen und dann machst du deinen Bachelor-FH. Machst dann gerne noch mal einen Master-FH. Mit dem Master-FH kannst du in Deutschland inzwischen auch wunderbar promovieren. Also, es geht auf jeden Fall.
Wir machen nachher noch ein bisschen Studienbeschreibung.
Ob du willst oder nicht. Die Frage, die ich noch stelle, ist, sollte man direkt am Anfang studieren, also quasi, ich mache Abi, ich habe Computer bis jetzt schon toll gefunden, und jetzt will ich in dem Bereich arbeiten. Soll ich da studieren? Oder ist es vielleicht tatsächlich die bessere Wahl, auch zu sagen, okay, ich mache mal vielleicht, also nicht mal eine Ausbildung, sondern ich arbeite einfach mal in dem Bereich und bringe mir selber Sachen bei und hole es dann später nach. Oder, das ist eigentlich die eigentliche Frage, wird das Informatikstudium umso frustrierender, je mehr ich schon weiß?
Ja, also das Problem ist auch, je länger du aus der Schule weg bist, umso schwieriger wird es dir fallen, dich hinzusetzen und wieder Sachen zu lernen. Das geht halt einfacher, wenn man da nicht so lange raus ist und einfach weitermachen kann.
Ich muss ja vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen ein Gegenmodell erzählen. Also mein Betriebswirtschaftsstudium, das war ein Studium an einer privaten Hochschule neben der Arbeit, wo der Arbeitgeber dazu beigetragen hat, dass ich Studium machen konnte. Und das war so völlig anders als an einer öffentlichen Hochschule zu studieren. Weil die Leute, die kamen aus der Praxis, die haben also alle 20 Jahre Berufserfahrung, denen hast du keinen Scheiß mehr erzählt. Die Blocksignale waren freitags und samstags. Das heißt, das was an der Uni über einen Semester geht mit jeweils Vorlesungen, wurde dir so am Stück von Freitag bis Samstag reingedrückt. Dann hast du hinterher den Vorlesenden bewertet und wenn er keine 1 gekriegt hat, wurde das Honorarium 20% gekürzt. Das sind unglaubliche Zustände. Dann bist nicht du dem Prüfungsamt hinterhergelaufen, sondern das Prüfungsamt ist dir. Da sind wir so, Herr Brug, Sie studieren jetzt schon 3 Jahre, wollen Sie nicht mal langsam? Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Zeit und so. Na ja, da können wir was einrichten, wir schicken Ihnen mal eine Verlängerung. Wann haben Sie Zeit für eine Prüfung? Am Ende des Tages hat mich das auch nicht mehr gekostet als an einer Uni mit Studiengebühren, die es ja immer noch gibt in Deutschland. Es kann ganz anders sein.
Was mir gerade auch auffällt ist, das wollte ich vorhin noch gefragt haben, diese Kombinationsinformatiken. Im Journalismus kenne ich ja so, es gibt ja Journalisten, die machen halt eine Ausbildung, also mit Volontariat und so was, und die arbeiten dann als Allrounder. Oder spezialisieren sich dann später, weil sie ein besonderes Thema haben. Oder, so wie ich, man studiert halt was ordentliches, also wait, nee, nach dieser Sendung kann ich das auch nicht mehr sagen, aber man studiert halt sozusagen eine Fachrichtung und bringt den Journalismus sozusagen selber bei. Und wird dann Fachjournalist in dem Sinne. Ist das bei der Informatik möglicherweise auch der bessere Weg oder ein anderer gangbarer Weg, dass man sagt, ich studiere nicht Bioinformatik, sondern ich studiere Biologie und helfe mir dann nebenbei noch das Programmieren auf, weil das eh das Wichtige ist? Skeptische Gesichter, Stirnrunzeln.
Da ist es befürchtet, teilweise zu spitz hier, oder?
Also zur Bioinformatik habe ich auch noch eine lustige Anekdote. Nämlich, dass irgendjemand, der früh mit dabei war von der Biologie-Seite, sich mit den Informatikern unterhalten hat und dann mal so erklärt hat, was er davon wollte. Und dann kamen die theoretischen Informatikern und sagten, okay, dein Problem ist NP-vollständig. Und dann sind sie wieder weggelaufen. Das heißt sozusagen, wir haben bewiesen, dass es theoretisch ein schweres Problem ist.
Okay, und dann hat er beschlossen, selber Informatik zu lernen, weil ihm dann nicht geholfen wurde.
Genau, und wie das immer so ist, natürlich gibt es sozusagen, die 100%-Lösung ist sozusagen so schwer, dass man sie nicht erreichen kann. Aber mit 99% der Lösung ist es in der Regel getan. Und man kann es auch machen, man kann auch medialistisch studieren und dann hinterher in die Programmierung gehen. Das ist auch gar kein Problem.
Okay, so, dann zum Abschluss noch, weil ich glaube, wir haben das Thema Schöpfen behandelt. Oder gibt es noch einen wichtigen Punkt, der euch auf der Seele brennt?
Wir sollten noch ein paar Minuten rein investieren, um zu sagen, dass alles nicht wirklich so dunkel ist, wie es gerade hier aussieht. Es ist durchaus positiv informativ studiert.
Jetzt entscheidet euch doch mal!
Es hat richtig Spaß gemacht.
Dass ihr in Stockholm studiert, ne? Wir gehen noch einmal das Sofa entlang und on a lighter note könnt ihr noch mal sagen, was das Schöne am Informatikstudium oder der Ausbildung war und was ihr euch vielleicht für die Zukunft wünscht und den Menschen, die dir überlegen, Informatik zu studieren, mit auf den Weg gehen wollt. Tobias, du hast ja gerade gesagt, noch ein paar Minuten kriegt man voll mit den schönen Dingen.
Das schöne Ding ist auf jeden Fall, dass man eine Möglichkeit hat, sich zu entfalten. Dass man überhaupt dieses generelle Studierending hat. Mutags hat so schön gesagt, man hat eigentlich es leichter, direkt nach der Schule morgens um 18 Uhr in der Vorlesung zu sitzen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, in meinen ersten Semestern saß ich nie, also nicht ganz nie, aber die Male, wo ich morgens um 18 Uhr in der Vorlesung saß, war ich betrunken und gerade aus der örtlichen Studentenknappe nach Hause gekommen, auf dem Weg nach Hause, zu Kommilitonen begegnet und dann in diesem Vorlesungssaal geendet. Also man kann da schon eine ganze Menge über sich selber, wie man arbeitet und generell über die Welt lernen und sich sehr entwickeln. Das sagt einigen Leuten zu, das sagt anderen Leuten total nicht zu und die kommen damit echt nicht klar. Aber ausprobieren.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich schreibe mich jetzt ein, ich gebe mir mal ein Jahr, um zu gucken. Ist das verschwendete Lebenszeit, wenn man sich dann entscheidet? Oder ist das so was, wo du sagst, das kann man auf jeden Fall mal machen?
Ich würde definitiv sagen, lieber ausprobieren als nicht ausprobieren.
Ausprobieren und auch an den Unis gibt es eigentlich überall irgendwelche Studenten, Initiativen, die sich da irgendwie engagieren, das Studium besser zu machen oder so. Und mit den Leuten kann man auch als Schüler reden und die fragen, wie ist das eigentlich bei euch? Was macht ihr hier eigentlich? Was ist spannend? Und normalerweise kriegt man da schon eine ganze Menge raus. Und das Schöne an Informatik ist eben, dass die Themengebiete so groß sind und es so viele verschiedene gibt, dass eigentlich für jeden was dabei ist. Also wenn man irgendwas mit Computern machen möchte, findet man da auf jeden Fall irgendwo so eine Ecke, in der man sich wohlfühlen kann und richtig Spaß haben kann. Und man kann halt Leuten helfen, Probleme zu lösen da draußen.
Ich hab mich mit der Frage beschäftigt, wem würde ich einer Ausbildung empfehlen und wem nicht. Ist gar nicht so einfach. Also ihr da draußen, wenn ihr euch schon lange mit so IT-Dingen beschäftigt und auch Leute kennt, meine Eltern werden jetzt wahrscheinlich von der Couch aufspringen und schreien, oh nein, nicht so unvernünftig, aber ich kenne genug Fälle in meinem Freundeskreis, wo es super funktioniert hat, dass sie ohne Ausbildung das machen, was sie können und wollen, was ihnen Spaß macht und sich damit auch unglaublich gut selber weiterbilden konnten. Da bleibt die Frage, für wen ist die Ausbildung jetzt richtig. Also natürlich für alle, die Drucker anschließen wollen sowieso, für alle, die Windows Domain administrieren wollen wahrscheinlich auch. Wenn ihr mehr wollt, kann die Ausbildung richtig sein, aber dann müsst ihr euch damit abfinden, dass die Berufsschule öde sein wird. Und kleiner Appell an alle Unternehmen und Personalabteilungen da draußen. Da draußen bezahlt eure Auszubildenden richtig. Nur weil alle machen, ist es noch lange nicht richtig. Also nur weil alle ihre Auszubildenden schlecht bezahlen, ist es noch lange nicht nicht scheiße. Und genau das ist so mein Appell.
Andreas noch?
Ja, ich würde sagen, ich würde studieren, allen Leuten empfehlen, die Spaß daran haben, sich einen Knoten ins Gehirn zu machen, ohne notwendigerweise sich die Frage dabei zu stellen, wofür das denn überhaupt gut sei. Es ist was für Leute mit Spaß am Denken, und je mehr man Spaß am Denken hat, desto mehr Spaß hat man beim Studium, und zwar ganz egal, was man studiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das letzte Wort ist, aber es ist einfach so. Gut, dann vielen Dank, Andreas, David, Mutax und Tobias. Viel Spaß euch noch in eurem Informatikerleben. Liebes Publikum, gibt es hier noch Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
Habt ihr praktische Erfahrungen oder Erfahrungen von Bekannten von euch, die jetzt weder eine Uni noch eine Ausbildung, sondern z.B. eine FH oder eine BA gemacht haben?
Was ist eine BA?
Berufsakademie, das ist was, was es glaube ich nur in Baden-Württemberg gibt. So ein bisschen fachhochschulmäßig, noch ein bisschen verschulte als Fachhochschule. Was aber bei Unternehmen da wohl sehr beliebt ist. Weil mir das so ein bisschen jetzt als Zwischenkontrast gefehlt hat. Weil ich den Eindruck hatte, dass viele Kommitonen, ich hab an der FH studiert, sehr begeistert waren, dass sie die FH quasi als Upgrade auf einer Ausbildung gemacht haben. Weil ihnen die Ausbildung nicht genug war und sie gesagt haben, okay, eigentlich kitzelt mich das intellektuell jetzt ein bisschen mehr zu machen. Ich möchte aber Praktiker bleiben und für die hat sich dann die FH als sehr lohnenswerter Zwischenschritt rausgestellt. Also kann ich nur sagen, die sind jetzt mit dem Job und mit dem Skillset, den sie entwickelt haben. Man muss dazu sagen, das waren auch sehr selbstmotivierte Leute. Sie sind hier super zufrieden gewesen. Das kommt halt immer auf den Typen an. Aber das ist jetzt noch so ein Aspekt, den ich finde, dass er relevant ist.
Wie gesagt, Softwareentwickler ist in meinen Augen eine typische FH-Geschichte. Also dass du das, wenn du wirklich programmieren möchtest und Software entwickeln möchtest, ist das eine Sache, wo du typischerweise in meinen Augen eine FH gehörst.
Wie lange dauert das? Genau, wie Uni ist es nur eine andere Ausrichtung?
Es ist dauermäßig genau das Gleiche. Also drei Jahre Bachelor, zwei Jahre Master. Wie gerade schon gesagt, auch mit Möglichkeit zu promovieren. Und viele machen dann im Gegensatz zu einem normalen Hochschulstudium tatsächlich beim Bachelor Schluss. Und das kann auch völlig okay sein. Also das ist tatsächlich dann eher so ein industrieakzeptierter Abschluss.
Apropos industrieakzeptierter Standards, eine Sache, die mir auch auch beantragt. Ich möchte mich beim Chaosradio Team bedanken, weil auf der Suche nach Gästen zu dieser Sendung haben die sich ganz viel Mühe gegeben, auch Gästinnen an den Start zu bekommen, was leider überhaupt nicht geklappt hat, weil die nicht konnten oder wollten. Aber noch mal für die Zuhörerinnen auch, ist diese Besetzung hier 100% männlich, ist das auch das Klischee des Informatikstudiums?
Es werden glücklicherweise immer mehr Frauen, aber es sind immer noch sehr wenige.
Es werden wieder mehr, muss man sagen. Mitte der 80er hat es mal gepiekt bei 40% Anteil und seitdem ist es runtergegangen. Gerade ändert sich das wieder so ein bisschen. Aber es ist tatsächlich nur Maschinenbau schlimmer. Vielschichtige Ursachen. Meines Erachtens daran, dass z.B. in den 80er Jahren Computerspiele hauptsächlich als Jungs-Spielzeug verkauft wurden. Deswegen standen bei den Jungs die Computern rum. Als diese Generation an die Unis gekommen ist, waren das die, die von klein auf schon Computer dastehen zu haben. Deswegen sind sie da reingerutscht. Aber das ist bestimmt auch eine eigene Sendung, das mal zu diskutieren.
Ich kenne solche Phänomene. Ein Ausbildungsleiter, den ich kenne von einem großen ISP, steht immer auf diesem Ausbildungsmessen, wo Schüler und Schülerinnen hingehen, um Dinge zu erfahren über Ausbildungsberufe. Dann kommen dann irgendwelche Schülerinnen zu dem Stand. Plötzlich steht dann die Tante daneben und zieht am Arm weg. Nee, das ist nichts für dich. Und das erlebt er leider immer wieder. Und dass das familiäre Umfeld sagt, mit dieser Technik, das ist nichts für dich, mach doch lieber was, was für Frauen richtig ist.
Dann möchte ich gleich ein bisschen das Mikrofon brechen und an dieser Stelle aber auch aufrufen. Informatikstudium ist eine schreckliche Angelegenheit, das soll aber jeder erfahren dürfen. Und jede vor allen Dingen. Gut, dann vielen Dank Andreas, David, Mutags, Tobias, dass ihr hier wart und uns einen Einblick gegeben habt. Vielen Dank ans Team Mo, Kai und Helena und Danimo. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich beschließe dieses Chaosradio 238. Habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.